This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. In the 3rd century BC, China's first emperor, Qin Shi Huang, made a bold proclamation. His dynasty would last 10,000 generations. He launched an obsessive quest for immortality. He ordered expeditions to the eastern sea, demanded his subject search for an elixir of life, and even welcomed mystics into his court. His obsession came at a cost, putting him at odds with Confucian scholars at the time. Historians have pieced together parts of Qin Shi Huang's story
这里是隐藏的大脑。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。公元前3世纪，中国的第一位皇帝秦始皇发表了一个大胆的宣言。他的王朝将延续1,0000代。他发起了一场对长生不老的痴迷追求。他下令远征东海，要求臣民寻找长生不老药，甚至迎请方士进入宫廷。他的痴迷付出了代价，使他与当时的儒家学者产生了分歧。历史学家们拼凑出了秦始皇故事的一部分，
from thousands of wooden strips unearthed in Hunan province. The strips documented his correspondence. These writings included responses from the emperor's minions who were too afraid to tell their boss what they really thought. According to the BBC, the notes featured, quote, assorted awkward replies from regional governments who had failed to find the key to eternal life. Chin Chi Huang did achieve extraordinary things during his lifetime.
这些内容来自湖南省出土的数千枚木简。这些木简记录了他的往来信件。这些文字包括皇帝手下的回复，他们太害怕而不敢告诉老板他们的真实想法。据英国广播公司报道，这些便条的特色是，引用，来自未能找到永生钥匙的地方政府的各种尴尬回复。秦始皇在他的一生中确实取得了非凡的成就。
He unified China, standardized currency and measures, built roads and canals, and linked fortresses into what became the Great Wall. But he never found the key to immortality. He died in 210 BC at the age of 49. Even in death, he refused to believe death was the end. His monumental mausoleum, guarded by thousands of terracotta soldiers, was designed to to protect him on its journey into the afterlife. What could cause such desperation, such obsession, such refusal to face the inevitable?
他统一了中国，统一了货币和度量衡，修建了道路和运河，并将堡垒连接成了后来的万里长城。但他从未找到通往永生的钥匙。他在公元前210年去世，享年49岁。即使在死后，他也拒绝相信死亡就是终点。他的巨大陵墓由数千名兵马俑守护，旨在保护他踏上通往来世的旅程。是什么导致了如此绝望、如此痴迷、如此拒绝面对不可避免的事情？
And is it possible that all of us share something in common with the great Chinese emperor? This is the second part of our exploration into how design thinking can help you lead a more meaningful life. If you miss the first story, you can find it in our podcast feed or at hiddenbrain.org. It's the episode titled, Designed, a life that matters, how we seek to avoid the truth and the costs of not facing reality. This week on Hidden Brain. Life isn't easy.
我们所有人是否有可能与这位中国伟大皇帝有某些共同点？这是我们关于设计思维如何帮助你过上更有意义的生活的探索的第二部分。如果你错过了第一个故事，你可以在我们的播客源或hiddenbrain.org上找到它。这一集的标题是，设计一个重要的人生，我们如何寻求逃避真相以及不面对现实的代价。本周在隐藏的大脑。生活并不容易。
There are times of joy, times of sorrow, and times of uncertainty. Along the way, we inevitably face setbacks, obstacles, and disappointment. At Stanford University, Dave Evans says that one way we cope with these challenges is by telling ourselves stories, narratives that help us make sense of what's happening to us. Dave Evans, welcome to Hidden Brain. Shankar, good to be with you again. Dave, you had a friend named Gary. How did the two of you meet and get to know each other? Well, our kids were of similar age and we frequented the same church. We lived in the same town, so we were neighbors. One day Gary came to you with a problem. Tell me what he told you. Well, his problem was he was having strokes.
有充满欢乐的时刻，有悲伤的时刻，也有充满不确定性的时刻。在这个过程中，我们不可避免地会面临挫折、障碍和失望。在斯坦福大学，戴夫·埃文斯说，我们应对这些挑战的一种方法是给自己讲故事，这些叙事帮助我们理解正在发生的事情。戴夫·埃文斯，欢迎来到隐藏的大脑。尚卡尔，很高兴再次和你在一起。戴夫，你曾有一个朋友叫加里。你们两个是怎么认识并了解彼此的？嗯，我们的孩子年龄相仿，我们经常去同一所教堂。我们住在同一个镇上，所以我们是邻居。有一天，加里带着一个问题来找你。告诉我他对你说了什么。嗯，他的问题是他中风了。
and it turned out he came from a long line of people who have strokes. He was a technical writer in Silicon Valley. We were in Silicon Valley. And he was having a good career. And his problem was how could he get back to working full time? He had had to take a stop out the way his stroke had hit him, was getting into a way of his ability to work. And he was wondering if I could help him figure out a way to get his skills back to where he could get back on the job.
结果发现他来自一个有中风家族史的家族。他是硅谷的技术作家。我们在硅谷。他的职业生涯很顺利。他的问题是如何才能回到全职工作状态？他不得不中断工作，中风对他的打击方式妨碍了他的工作能力。他想知道我是否能帮他想办法恢复技能，以便能够重返工作岗位。
So his problem was, he said, I have a job that I like. I'm doing what I want to do, but I have this pesky little thing, which is my body is not allowing me to do what I want to do. And I want you to get my body out of the way so I can go back to doing what I want to do. Right. You said, well, you know, this, I mean, the problem is, Deb, I, you know, my father died of a stroke. My brother died of a stroke in his late 50s. He was about 52 at the time, something like that. He said, so I don't want to be that guy. Why is this happening? Everything's got to happen for a reason. must be that there's something I'm supposed to learn. So if I were, if I could learn what it is,
所以他的问题是，他说，我有一份喜欢的工作。我在做我想做的事，但我有这个烦人的小问题，那就是我的身体不让我做我想做的事。我希望你把我的身体挡开，这样我就可以回去做我想做的事。对。你说，好吧，你知道，这个，我的意思是，问题是，德布，我，你知道，我父亲死于中风。我哥哥在50多岁时死于中风。他当时大约52岁，诸如此类。他说，所以不想成为那样的人。为什么会这样？凡事必有因。一定有什么事是我应该学的。所以如果我，如果我能学到是什么，
that this malady has tried to teach me, then maybe it can stop and I can get my life back. So what I really need to do is figure out why I need to learn something from this and what is it. Can you help me with that? I'm wondering how you responded to this request of his to help him understand what the, his body was trying to tell him, the message it was trying to give him. I was stuck a little bit because I thought, oh, my God, I don't think that's what's going on. And here's this guy, who's a lovely guy. And the truth is he's dying. The truth is he's got a severe medical threat, and it's not going well.
这个病试图教导我的东西，也许它就会停止，我就可以找回我的生活。所以我真正需要做的是弄清楚为什么我需要从中学习一些东西以及它是什么。你能帮我这个忙吗？我想知道你是如何回应他这个请求的，他请求你帮他理解他的身体试图告诉他的事情，它试图传授给他的信息。我有点卡住了，因为我想，哦，天哪，我觉得事情不是这样的。这里有这个人，他是个可爱的人。事实是他在死去。事实是，他面临着严峻的医疗威胁，情况很不妙。
And he's counting on me to help him get some place I don't think he can go. So what I was really struggling with is how do I deliver the bad news that, Gary, I think you're asking the wrong question. Hmm. I'm wondering whether Gary was getting full. feedback from other people that was trying to answer the question that he wanted answered, even if it wasn't the right question? Well, yes, unfortunately, he was surrounded with well-meaning cheerful people who wanted him to feel better, you know, and so there were a group of guys he regularly had lunch with,
他指望我帮他去一个我认为他去不了的地方。所以我真正挣扎的是，我如何传达这个坏消息：加里，我觉得你问错问题了。嗯。我想知道加里是否从其他人那里得到了充分的反馈，这些反馈试图回答他想要回答的问题，即使这不是正确的问题？嗯，是的，不幸的是，他被一些出于好意、开朗的人包围着，他们希望他感觉好点，你知道，所以有一群他经常一起吃午饭的人，
and they were encouraging, like, you can do this, Gary. And he goes, I'm going to try to get back to where they go, that's great, you keep going, buddy, you know, so they all were trying to cheerlead. And unfortunately, they were cheerleading him down there I thought it was a dead end that It was going to end very, very badly. So, you know, there's the old phrase, the road to hell is paved with good intention. There's a lot of good intention surrounding him. But frankly, I think it was going a terrible place.
他们很鼓励，比如，你能做到，加里。他说，我要试着回到他们去的地方，那太好了，老兄，继续前进，你知道，所以他们都在试图加油。不幸的是，他们鼓励他走向我认为是死胡同的方向，事情会以非常非常糟糕的方式结束。所以，你知道，有一句老话，通往地狱的道路是由好意铺就的。他周围有很多好意。但坦率地说，我认为事情会走向一个糟糕的结局。
It must have placed you in a very difficult situation, Dave, because a friend is coming to you with this very serious problem. You feel like your friend is not looking at reality for what it is. Other friends are basically encouraging Gary in his delusion. What did you do? Well, keep in mind, I met Gary at church, which means, you know, he was a person of faith, and that was a big part of the story. And so it wasn't just what's the lesson that my body's trying to teach me, but what is God trying to tell me? Because I'm pretty sure this must be a lesson God is giving me that if I can persevere through
这一定让你陷入了非常困难的境地，戴夫，因为一个朋友带着这个非常严重的问题来找你。你觉得你的朋友没有正视现实。其他朋友基本上都在鼓励加里的妄想。你做了什么？嗯，请记住，我在教堂遇到了加里，这意味着，你知道，他是一个有信仰的人，那是故事的重要组成部分。所以这不仅是我的身体试图教给我的教训是什么，而且是上帝试图告诉我什么？因为我很确定这一定上帝给我的教训，如果我能坚持下去
and learn a lesson, then I'd get to get out of jail. You know, and I didn't think that was likely to happen, because despite the fact that I, too, happen to believe in God, God doesn't fix every problem. God doesn't insert himself and miraculously fix everything. That's a whole different understanding. And it's nice to think that's what's coming your way, but you're not in charge of that. You may not be the miracle child. And so I asked him, point in black note, Gary, why is it you believe this?
并吸取教训，那么我就可以出狱了。你知道，我不认为这会发生，因为尽管事实上我也碰巧相信上帝，但上帝并不解决所有问题。上帝不会介入并奇迹般地解决一切。这是一个完全不同的理解。认为好事会降临到你身上是很好的，但你并不负责控制这个。你可能不是奇迹之子。所以我斩钉截铁地问他，加里，你为什么相信这一点？
And he said, well, what else could it possibly be? There's got to be a reason for this. I said, well, let's look at what the other reasons might be. Could we just do that? I said, well, okay. He said, what do you mean? I said, well, maybe the reason you're having strokes, Gary, isn't because God is going to use you as the demonstration of a miracle,
他说，除此之外还能是什么？这一定有原因。我说，好吧，让我们看看其他可能的原因是什么。我们能这样做吗？我说，好吧，可以。他说，你是什么意思？我说，好吧，也许你中风的原因，加里，不是因为上帝要用你作为奇迹的示范，
but maybe you're having strokes because you've got really crappy DNA and brain chemistry that breaks down at about 50 to 55 years old. Because, you know, we live in a broken world, and some of that brokenness falls on everybody. We're all going to die, by the way. All we're talking about is timing. And I told him the story of the head of the geron talk, Department at Harvard Medical School, who I got stuck on the ground during an ice storm in Chicago
而是也许你中风是因为你拥有非常糟糕的DNA和脑化学物质，在50到55岁左右就会崩溃。因为，你知道，我们生活在一个破碎的世界里，一部分破碎会降临到每个人身上。顺便说一句，我们都会死。我们谈论的全部只是时间问题。我给他讲了哈佛医学院老年医学系主任的故事，多年前在芝加哥的一场冰风暴中，我和他在地面上受困
with years ago, who reminded me, almost nobody dies of old age. They die of disease or starvation or an accident. I said, so Gary, you're not going to die of old age. You're going to dive something else, and maybe you're going to dive a stroke. So maybe what's going on is, how do you live well through being a person who comes from a long line of guys with bad stroke DNA? And he just stared at me. He said, do you think that might be it? I said, well, Gary, lots of people die in their 50s. You might be one of them. He said, well, if that's what's going on, what do I do?
提醒我，几乎没有人是老死的。他们死于疾病、饥饿或事故。我说，所以加里，你不会老死。你会死于其他事情，也许你会死于中风。所以也许发生的事情是，作为一个来自有糟糕中风DNA家族的人，你如何过好生活？他只是盯着我看了看。他说，你觉得会是这样吗？我说，好吧，加里，很多人在50多岁时去世。你可能是其中之一。他说，好吧，如果这是怎么回事，我该怎么办？
I said, well, you do this as well as you can. So we had a long conversation about that. It must have been very difficult for you to say what you said to him, Dave, but also very difficult for him to listen to it. This is not the kind of thing that a friend is supposed to tell you. Well, this is where we make the distinction between nice and loving. You know, are you trying to be nice to somebody?
我说，好吧，你要尽可能好地做到这一点。所以我们为此进行了长谈。对你来说，对他说你所说的话一定非常困难，戴夫，但对他来说听进去也很困难。这不是朋友应该对你说的那种话。嗯，这就是我们在“好”和“有爱”之间做出区别的地方。你知道，你是在试图对别人好吗？
You're trying to love them. And sometimes that love, I don't mean tough love, and you have to beat them up. I wasn't trying to be unkind. But if it's true that he's going to die of a stroke, which he did, about four strokes later,
你是在试着爱他们。有时那种爱，我不是指严厉的爱，你必须打他们。我不是想刻薄。但如果事实是他会死于中风，他确实死于中风，大约四次中风之后，
then either he's going to do that and be blindsided by it and terrified at the moment of death and leave his family in some despair about his final days, or he's got a little more time to do this well. So what's the kindest thing I can do? The kindest thing I can do is give him a shot at the invitation
那么要么他会这样做，并在毫无防备的情况下被打个措手不及，在临终时感到恐惧，让他的家人对他的最后几天感到绝望，要么他还有多一点时间把这件事做好。那么我能做的最善良的事是什么？我能做的最善良的事就是给他一个接受邀请的机会
to actually find the meaning and the joy that is available. I'm not in charge of his fixing his brain, but I might be able to give him an invitation to a little more life-giving experience than he's currently having. I'm wondering how Gary took your advice and what he did with it. Well, we had that conversation, and he received it reasonably well, well, but I mean, it was really hard and it was pretty quiet.
去真正找到可用的意义和快乐。我无法负责修复他的大脑，但我或许能给他一个邀请，让他体验到比他目前更具生命力的经历。我想知道加里是如何接受你的建议的，他用它做了什么？嗯，我们进行了那次交谈，他接受得还算合理，好，但我的意思是，这真的很艰难，而且非常安静。
And his wife, Kathy, was in the kitchen and over here, you know, and it was kind of gave us some space. And I didn't really know what was going on. I bumped into his wife in the supermarket about three weeks later. And she walks up to me, she goes, what was it? You said to Gary. And I thought, oh, man, this is going to go badly. And I said, well, this is what I said.
他的妻子凯西在厨房里，在这边，你知道，这给了我们一些空间。我真的不知道发生了什么。大约三周后，我在超市撞见了。她走向我，说，你对加里说了什么？我想，哦，天哪，这要糟糕了。我说，好吧，这就是我说的。
And she said, well, it made all the difference in the world. world. He's a changed man. He's finally at peace. It was amazing. Thank you. And two person into tears. So a few, you know, dodged that bullet, but, you know, it's kind of hitting me again. This life stuff, you know, it's pretty serious, but it's the best thing we've got. And so the invitation is, would you like to participate? And he died well. When we come back, why the most important thing might not be figuring out where you want to go, but accepting where it is you are. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
她说，这产生了巨大的影响。他变了个人。他终于平静下来了。太神奇了。谢谢。两人感动得热泪盈眶。所以，你知道，躲过了那一劫，但，你知道，这又一次击中了我的心。这生活的事，你知道，挺严肃的，但这是我们拥有的最好的东西。所以邀请是，你想参与吗？他死得很好。当我们回来时，为什么最重要的事情可能不是弄清楚你想去哪里，而是接受你现在在哪里。你正在收听的是隐藏的大脑。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. At Stanford University, Dave Evans studies a concept called design thinking. He says that the same principles that engineers and innovators use to solve complex problems can also be applied to designing our lives, making them more meaningful, joyful, and fulfilling. Dave, we talked about your friend Gary, who was in denial about the seriousness of his strokes. You told him he had two options, to die well or to go out kicking and screaming. I want to go back to early March of 2020. The COVID pandemic had just broken and worries about illness were on all of our minds. Paint a picture for me of what was happening in your life
这里是隐藏的大脑。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在斯坦福大学，戴夫·埃文斯研究一个名为设计思维的概念。他说，工程师和创新者用来解决复杂问题的相同原则也可以应用于设计我们的生活，使其更有意义、更快乐、更充实。戴夫，我们谈到了你的朋友加里，他对中风的严重性持否认态度。你告诉他有两个选择，要么死得好，要么大喊大叫地离开。我想回到2020年3月上旬。新冠疫情刚刚爆发，对疾病的担忧都在我们所有人的脑海中。给我描绘一下你生活中的情景
at the time. Well, at the end of February, we were reeling from the fact that these things might be coming, just the news coming out of China was happening. And then on March 8th, you know, it took my wife Claudia to the local little walk-in clinic because she'd gotten her Christmas cold in New York. In late December, we often go to New York between Christmas and New Year's for fun. And she always comes home with a Christmas cold. But it held on and held on. And it lasted through January. And she was coughing all the time.
当时。嗯，在2月底，我们还在为这些事情可能会到来而感到震惊，仅仅是来自中国的新闻发生了。然后在3月8日，你知道，我带我的妻子克劳迪娅去了当地的小型步入式诊所，因为她在纽约得了圣诞感冒。在12月下旬，我们经常在圣诞节和新年之间去纽约玩。她总是带着圣诞感冒回家。但它一直持续着。它持续了整个一月。她一直在咳嗽。
I said, honey, this is not okay. So we went in to the clinic. And the clinic said, oh, there's more going on here. You need to go to the ER. We went to the ER. And then they pumped out a liter and a half of fluid from her. lungs and said, we need to test this. And so we're going to send it over to the lab to test. And we're going to send it back to Stanford. And so then a couple of weeks after the tests were all
我说，亲爱的，这可不行。所以我们去了诊所。诊所说，哦，这里还有其他情况。你需要去急诊室。我们去了急诊室。然后他们从她的肺里抽出了升半的液体，
done, we got to go on March 8th to Stanford to hear the news. And the news was that she had terminal cancer. She was already metastasized four times, and she had six to 24 months to live. I cannot imagine how this news must have struck you, Dave. How did you and Claudia react? Well, we knew things weren't good when they pumped all that junk out of her lungs. But We didn't know it was fatal. And so jumping from, you've got a really bad bronchitis to your dying was quite a leap. It hit us very hard, but it just hit us. And we said, oh, what do we do with this?
肺部说，我们需要检测这个。所以我们要把它送到实验室去检测。我们要把它送回斯坦福。所以在那之后的几个星期里，当测试都完成后，我们得在3月8日去斯坦福听取消息。消息是她得了晚期癌症。她已经转移了四次，只有6到24个月的寿命了。我无法想象这个消息对你的打击有多大，戴夫。你和克劳迪娅是如何反应的？嗯，当他们把那些垃圾从她肺里抽出来时，我们就知道情况不妙了。但我们不知道是致命的。所以从“你得了很严重的支气管炎”跨越到“你要死了”是一个巨大的飞跃。这对我们打击很大，但它就是发生了。我们说，哦，我们该怎么处理这个？
Well, the first thing we said, we've got to receive this. So we didn't tell anybody. We sat on it privately for about eight days with the idea being let it sink in and then decide, what's the story? What are we doing here? We have all these people. And at the end of that week, we conclude, if actually Claudia concluded, she says, here it is. The one-liner is, I'm dying.
嗯，我们说的第一件事是，我们必须接受这一点。所以我们没有告诉任何人。我们私下里对此保持了大约八天，想法是让它沉淀下来，然后决定，故事是什么？我们在这里做什么？我们有这么多人。在那周末结束时，我们得出结论，实际上克劳迪娅得出结论，她说，就是这样。一句话概括是，我要死了。
It's sad, but not tragic. She was 69 at the time. It lived a very full life. There was really nothing left on our bucket list, nothing we needed to do, lots we wanted to do, hadn't even begun to be retired people. But nonetheless, no regrets. And so she chose to live into her final months saying, sooner than I had in mind, but let's be honest, this is just sad, not tragic.
这很悲伤，但不是悲剧。她当时69岁。过着非常充实的生活。我们的愿望清单上真的没有什么没做过的，没有什么需要做的，有很多想做的，甚至还没有开始做退休人员。但尽管如此，毫无遗憾。所以她选择在她的最后几个月里生活，说，比我预想的要早，但老实说，这只是悲伤，不是悲剧。
Let's make the most of the time. And that's what we announced to our family and friends, and that begat, what turned out to be nine months. She got nine months. She died in December. She died five years ago this Thursday. And that was probably one of the most intense and actually one of the most wonderful years of my life. It's strange that you say that it was a wonderful year of your life, Dave. Many people would say, you know, I went through the whole year with a sense of dread and a sense of grief and a sense that, oh my God, why is this happening to me?
让我们充分利用时间。这就是我们向家人和朋友宣布的，这开启了后来证明是九个月的生活。她得到了九个月。她在12月去世。这个星期四是她去世五周年。那可能是我一生中最 intense 且实际上最美好的几年之一。你说那是你生命中美好的一年，这很奇怪，戴夫。很多人会说，你知道，我带着恐惧感、悲伤感和“哦，天哪，为什么这会发生在我身上”的感觉度过了整整一年。
How come those things didn't happen to you? Well, there was that incredible year of her dying. And then there was the year after she died. And I often tell people the best year of my marriage is the year after my wife died because I learned so much about her. The reason it was different for us was simply this acceptance. We really do believe that reality is the only place anything can possibly happen. And so we deferred all that what's next and why me because frankly, none of that matters. What was true was she was going to die.
为什么那些事情没有发生在你身上？嗯，那是她去世那不可思议的一年。然后是她去世后的一年。我经常告诉人们，我婚姻中最美好的一年是我妻子去世后的一年，因为我从她身上学到了很多东西。对我们来说不同的原因很简单，就是这种接受。我们真的相信现实是唯一可能发生任何事情的地方。所以我们推迟了所有“接下来是什么”和“为什么是我”，因为坦率地说，这些都不重要。事实是她要死了。
So our choices were to be present to that or to be absent to that. And, you know, we lived very publicly. We have a lot of people. We wrote about it. And a lot of people walked alongside us. So we kept hearing people saying, gosh, you're doing such a noble job. Well, thank you. And I'm honored that people think that.
所以我们的选择是面对现实还是逃避现实。而且，你知道，我们生活得很公开。我们有很多人。我们写下了它。很多人陪在我们身边。所以我们一直听到人们说，天哪，你做得太高尚了。好吧，谢谢。我很荣幸人们会这么认为。
And technically it was true. my vet, who's a good friend of mine, said, man, I don't know anybody going through this the way you guys are doing this. And I said, well, Dave, his name is Dave, too. Thanks for saying that. I got to be honest with you. We're just trying to take the easiest path we can. Most people who are in denial and resistance
技术上这也是真的。我的兽医，我的一个好朋友，说，天哪，我不知道有谁像你们这样经历过这个。我说，好吧，戴夫，他的名字也叫Dave。谢谢你这么说。我得老实说。我们只是在寻找最轻松的道路。大多数处于否认和抵抗状态的人
just make it harder and more painful. We're just trying to do this thing as easily as we possibly can. You know, Dave, we've talked about the five stages of grief that have been in the popular culture for a very long time. And in some ways, it's not a very good accounting of the story of grief because the original work was done with patients who had terminal diagnoses and the research was looking at how they responded to the news of their own impending death. But it talks about going through these
只会让事情变得更艰难、更痛苦。我们只是想尽可能轻松地完成这件事。你知道，戴夫，我们讨论了流行文化中存在很长时间的悲伤的五个阶段。在某些方面，它并不是对悲伤故事的很好描述，因为最初的工作是对患有终末期诊断的患者进行的，研究着眼于他们如何对自己的迫在死讯做出反应。但它谈到了经历这些
phases of denial and anger and bargaining and depression before getting to acceptance. What you and Claudia did was cut out those first four steps and just get to the last one. Yeah, we had really worked on being good acceptors for a long time. You know, we were a second marriage. We had both been through failed marriages, and we understood the finitude of relationship, and we were thrilled to be happily married to somebody. They were not horrible marriages, but marriages that didn't last, and we were thrilled that we had a second shot.
在接受之前经历否认、愤怒、讨价还价和抑郁的阶段。你和克劳迪娅所做的是跳过了前四个步骤，直接进入了最后一步。是的，我们长期以来一直在努力成为良好的接受者。你知道，这是我们的第二次婚姻。我们都经历过失败的婚姻，我们理解关系的有限性，我们很高兴能与某人幸福地结婚。那些婚姻并非糟糕，只是没有持续，我们很高兴我们有了第二次机会。
One of our kids, you know, is bipolar and drags a heavy bag behind him. He's now happily married with two kids. has a wonderful life, but it didn't come easy. You know, and these are not things you can negotiate easily with. You can't tell a bipolar brain, why do you just behave better? So we had already been around a lot of things not of our choosing. You know, my father killed himself when I was nine. So reality was something that we had been in school with before,
我们的一个孩子，你知道，患有双相情感障碍，背着沉重的包袱。他现在幸福地结婚了，有两个孩子，生活很美好，但这并不容易。你知道，这些不是你可以轻易协商的事情。你不能对一个双相情感障碍的大脑说，你为什么不能表现得更好一点？所以我们已经经历过很多并非我们选择的事情。你知道，我父亲在我九岁时自杀身亡。所以现实是我们以前上过学的科目，
and that allowed us to go to acceptance first. The long, slow path to it doesn't look attractive to me. Can you talk about how this idea of not just acceptance but radical acceptance is at the heart of design thinking? Before we can figure out where we want to go, we have to fully accept where we are. Yeah, acceptance is step zero. Before you can even begin formally, the first step in design is empathy, deeply understanding what's going on. But before you even do that deep understanding, you have to be willing to accept. And that is what is in fact true. because reality is the only place things actually work.
这使我们能够首先走向接受。通往它的漫长而缓慢的道路对我没有吸引力。你能谈谈这种不仅是接受而且是彻底接受的想法如何成为设计思维的核心吗？在我们弄清楚我们想去哪里之前，我们必须完全接受我们现在在哪里。是的，接受是第零步。在你甚至可以正式开始之前，设计的第一个步骤是同理心，深入了解正在发生的事情。但在你做这种深入理解之前，你必须愿意接受。这就是实际真实的情况。因为现实是事情真正起作用的唯一地方。
Radical acceptance is literally as best you possibly can to eliminate any vestige of resistance that this is in fact exactly the way things currently are. So as people are designing their lives or asking to design their lives, they're often asking where I want to go and they're often upset or angry with their present circumstances in some way. They basically say it's not fair.
彻底接受字面意思是尽你所能消除对这正是目前现状的任何抵抗痕迹。因此，当人们在设计自己的生活或被要求设计自己的生活时，他们经常问我想去哪里，他们经常对自己的现状感到某种不满或愤怒。他们基本上说这不公平。
You know, I did all the things I should have done, but I'm not where I should be in my career. Or I, you know, I've done everything that I should, but I'm not in a happy relationship. And I should be in a happy relationship. And so they have a sense of fairness, a sense of anger. Talk about how, in some ways, these get in the way of seeing reality accurately. It's all about this what I had in mind thing. You know, let's go back to Allison. We talked about it in the previous episode.
你知道，我做了所有我应该做的事情，但我没有达到我职业生涯中应该达到的位置。或者我，你知道，我做了所有我应该做的，但我没有处于一段幸福的关系中。我应该处于一段幸福的关系中。所以他们有一种公平感，一种愤怒感。谈谈在某些方面，这些是如何妨碍准确看待现实的。这一切都与我心中的想法有关。你知道，让我们回到艾莉森。我们在上一集里谈过这个。
You know, here's, I'm talking to a group of accountants, and here's this lovely middle-aged woman, and she's reasonably happily married and got two reasonably decent kids and a reasonably paid off car, a small business working with a lot of other small businesses, except she's a little bit bored to tears and mostly just not feeling it. And what did I do wrong? Well, she didn't do anything wrong. I said, look, why did you pick accounting? Well, you know, because it's predictable and I really like having the right answer. I like knowing I've done the right thing well.
你知道，这里是，我正在跟一群会计师谈话，这是一个可爱的中年女性，婚姻还算幸福，有两个还算正派的孩子，一辆还算付清贷款的车，一个小企业，跟很多其他小企业合作，除了她有点无聊到死，主要就是没感觉。我做错了什么？嗯，她没做错什么。我说，听着，你为什么选择会计？嗯，你知道，因为它是可预测的，我真的很喜欢有正确的答案。我喜欢知道我把正确的事情做好了。
I go, great. So you're in a very uncreative business because you like stability. And why did you pick small businesses, you know, as your clients? Well, you know, they're cash operated businesses and they pay in cash, you know, and I don't want to be in debt. And I understand their business because they're kind of like me. So I think I understand that. You know, that's something I can really handle pretty well. So, oh, so you don't want to go outside your comfort zone because you really like being in your comfort zone.
我说，太棒了。所以你从事的是一个非常缺乏创造力的商业，因为你喜欢稳定。你为什么选择小企业，你知道，作为你的客户？嗯，你知道，它们是现金运营的企业，用现金支付，你知道，我不想负债。我理解他们的业务，因为他们有点像我。所以我认为我理解这一点。你知道，那是我真的可以处理得相当好的事情。所以，哦，所以你不想走出你的舒适区，因为你真的很喜欢呆在舒适区。
That's great, you know. And so we ended up describing that she got exactly what she wanted, which came with predictability and stability. like Stasis and it's not very creative and it's not very exciting and it's not very scary either. So she got exactly what she wanted. There's no surprise here whatsoever. And so what you sort of forgot to accept, Allison, is that that stability is not the same as a high learning curve. And that small business is not going to make you rich because you're operating on a cash basis. You're not, you know, working 80 hours a week to try to get founder stock in some venture capital-based firm.
那太棒了，你知道。所以我们最终描述的是，她得到了她正好想要的东西，这带来了可预测性和稳定性。像停滞不前的状态，它不是很富有创造力，也不是很令人兴奋，也不是很吓人。所以她得到了她正好想要的东西。这里没有任何惊喜。所以你有点忘了接受的一点是，艾莉森，这种稳定并不等于高学习曲线。那个小企业也不会让你发财，因为你是基于现金运营的。你不是，你知道，每周工作80个小时去试图在某个风险投资公司获得创始人股权。
So these things are exactly what you wanted all along. they just come with consequences. So can we accept the fact that you got exactly what you wanted? And now how do you make the most of what that is? So very often we simply aren't telling ourselves enough truth. I want to look at some of the ways in which we do not live in reality because the ways in which we dodge reality are sometimes subtle. You once knew a high-powered corporate executive who worked in tech.
所以这些事情完全是你一直想要的。它们只是附带后果。所以我们能接受你得到了你一直想要的东西这个事实吗？现在你如何充分利用它？所以很多时候我们只是没有对自己说足够的实话。我想看看我们不生活在现实中的一些方式，因为我们逃避现实的方式有时是微妙的。你曾经认识一位从事科技的高级企业高管。
He was very successful, and he was presented with an ambitious problem, that he desperately wanted to solve. Can you tell me his story, Dave? Yeah, well, we'll call him George, and he was working at high tech and he was doing well, but he was also a caring guy and who was involved in his local church and in his community and came along the idea of fair trade
他非常成功，并且被提出了一个雄心勃勃的问题，这是他迫切想要解决的。你能给我讲讲他的故事吗，戴夫？嗯，好吧，我们叫他乔治，他在高科技行业工作，干得很好，但他也一个富有同情心的人，参与了当地教堂和社区的活动，偶然想到了公平贸易的想法
and working with organizations, particularly in West Africa, where we're putting villagers to work and trying to help them engage in the capitalistic world by going through fair trade companies. And he got this notion, notion that what he needed to do was start a fair trade company that would create these craft companies in West Africa. And he not only decided that that was something that he thought was really interesting,
并与组织合作，特别是西非的组织，我们在那里让村民工作，试图通过公平贸易公司帮助他们融入资本主义世界。他有了这个想法，认为他需要做的是创办一家公平贸易公司，在西非创建这些手工艺品公司。他不只决定那是他认为非常有趣的事情，
but that was really what God wanted him to do, that that was going to make the world a better place. He was going to lift people out of poverty, and he was going to do this noble thing. And off he went, and he left his home country in Europe and moved his family and went through all this incredible effort, you know, which was a very noble idea. but it didn't work out the way you had in mind. What happened? Why did it not work out? Well, this is one of those situations where, you know,
但这真的是上帝希望他做的，那会让世界变得更美好。他将把人们从贫困中解救出来，他要做这件高尚的事情。于是他出发了，离开了他的欧洲祖国，搬了家，付出了所有难以置信的努力，你知道，这是一个非常高尚的想法。但它并没有按照你心中的想法发展。发生了什么？为什么没有成功？嗯，这是那些情况之一，你知道，
how committed to reality are you versus how committed to what you're aspiring towards? It's lovely to have an aspiration, but is that aspiration getting in the way of reality? And so he starts this company, off it goes. Of course, it's a very slow beginning, you know, and it reaches a certain degree of success, and he then wants to grow up to the next day, And in fact, not only does it not go to the next stage, it starts to falter. And so this thing begins to fail a little bit. And then he tries to shoulder it up again with his own labor and a little bit of his own money.
你对现实的承诺与你对愿望的承诺相比如何？有愿望是美好的，但这个愿望是否妨碍了现实？于是他创办了这家公司，它开始了。当然，这是一个非常缓慢的开始，你知道，它达到了某种程度的成功，然后他想要成长到下一阶段，事实上，不仅没有进入下一阶段，它开始步履蹒跚。所以这东西开始有点失败了。然后他试图用自己的劳动和一点点自己的钱再次撑起它。
And he keeps putting good money after bad in a year after year. And he does this for a period of about five years. And finally had to set the company down. The company so failed, you know, that his investors and supporters said, look, it's too much. You've got to give up. But he went bitter because for a couple of years after that, He just can, you know, God's punishing me.
他年复一年地把好钱扔进无底洞。他这样做了大约五年。最后不得不关闭公司。公司失败得太厉害了，你知道，他的投资者和支持者说，听着，这太多了。你必须放弃。但他变得很痛苦，因为在那之后的几年里，他只能，你知道，上帝在惩罚我。
And I said, George, look, I mean, you tried real hard. You gave it the old college try and it didn't work out. You know, God's right next to you saying, shoot, George, I wish you to work too. You didn't do anything wrong. But you're making up a story about the way things deserve to be, which is not how they are. So radical acceptance precedes any real meaning making. I want to drill down on the idea that accepting reality is not the same thing as endorsing reality. You're not saying that we have to accept that we are stuck in reality.
我说，乔治，听着，我的意思是，你真的很努力。你做出了真诚的尝试，但没有成功。你知道，上帝就在你旁边说，哎呀，乔治，我也希望它能成功。你没做错什么。但你在编造一个关于事物应有样子的故事，而事实并非如此。所以彻底接受先于任何真正的意义创造。我想深入探讨这个想法，即接受现实并不等于认可现实。你并不是说我们必须接受我们陷入现实中。
There may be things that we can do to get ourselves unstuck. But the starting point of any design exercise is to clearly see where we are. Can you talk about this idea? Because some of the problems that people have in their lives involve things that are genuinely upsetting. You know, a cancer diagnosis is genuinely upsetting. it's unfair. Or we might be struggling with some kind of problem involving a social injustice. And you're not basically saying accepting reality for what it is means that you have to endorse reality for what it is.
我们可能会做一些事情来摆脱困境。但任何设计练习的出发点都是清晰地看到我们身处何方。你能谈谈这个想法吗？因为人们生活中的一些问题涉及真正令人不安的事情。你知道，癌症诊断确实令人不安。这很不公平。或者我们可能在挣扎某种涉及社会不公的问题。你基本上不是说接受现实的本来面目意味着你必须认可现实的本来面目。
I'm really glad you asked the question. It comes up all the time. And it's a crucial question. And it's one that some people really, really struggle with, particularly around, you know, moral issues or social issues. In fact, I'll be a very real example. A lovely young woman that I've been mentoring for over 20 years, she's my chosen daughter. you know, found herself once again working for a ridiculously horrible boss. I mean, this is a bona fide, bad boss. I said, you've got to accept that this guy is a raging, nasty person, and it's not going to get any better. But I can't accept that.
我很高兴你问了这个问题。这个问题经常出现。这是一个至关重要的问题。这也是一些人真正、真正挣扎的问题，特别是在围绕道德问题或社会问题时。事实上，我举一个非常真实的例子。我指导了20多年的一位可爱的年轻女性，她是我选择的女儿。你知道，发现自己再次为一位荒谬糟糕的老板工作。我的意思是，这是一个名副其实的糟糕老板。我说，你必须接受这家伙是个狂暴、讨厌的人，而且不会变好。但我无法接受这一点。
That means I'm going to be oppressed forever. And I said, wait, wait, wait, you can't be effective unless you can accept this. You've got to accept that nothing you're going to do is going to change his mind. Nothing you're going to do is going to make him happy. He's always going to be unhappy. he's always going to treat you badly. But what you can do is you can minimize the damage. What you can do is you can get the heck out of there eventually, which he did.
这意味着我将永远被压迫。我说，等等，等等，等等，除非你能接受这一点，否则你不会有效率。你必须接受你做的任何事都无法改变他的想法。你做的任何事都无法让他快乐。他永远都不会快乐。他总是会对你很差。但你能做的是你可以把损害降到最低。你能做的是你最终可以离开那里，她确实这样做了。
And the reason that's always empowering is that it gives you the capacity to actually do what can be effectively done rather than find yourself simply standing outside of reality. Like you're locked outside. Well, standing outside and banging on the door of reality and complaining doesn't change the thing. But getting inside. reality and acting effectively can. So that distinction between endorsing it and accepting is a really important distinction, particularly if you're ever going to get in any difficult, you know, gray versus black and white
之所以这总是赋予力量，是因为它赋予了你实际去做可以有效完成的事情的能力，而不是发现自己只是站在现实之外。就像你被锁在外面一样。好吧，站在外面敲击现实的门并抱怨并不能改变事情。但进入现实内部并采取有效行动可以。所以，在认可和接受之间的区别是一个非常重要的区别，特别是如果你打算进入任何困难的、你知道的黑白分明
situation, you've got to keep endorsement and acceptance distinct. We talked earlier about the story of your friend Gary, Dave, when he was dealing with his very serious health conditions. He was initially in denial about them. You contrast Gary's story with the story of a man named Arnie, an artist in Atlanta. Paint me a picture of Arnie's life and tell me what you learned from him. Well, Arnie is quite a guy. In fact, I've talked to him just recently. We actually had the privilege of taking him to his 90th birthday dinner about a year ago.
情况，你必须保持认可和接受的区别。我们之前谈到了你的朋友加里的故事，戴夫，当时他正在处理非常严重的健康状况。他最初对它们持否认状态。你将加里的故事与一个名叫阿尼的男人的故事进行了对比，阿尼是亚特兰大的一位艺术家。给我描绘一下阿尼的生活，并告诉我你从他身上学到了什么。嗯，阿尼是个了不起的人。事实上，我最近才和他谈过。大约一年前，我们实际上有幸带他去参加他的90岁生日晚宴。
He's pushing 91. It turns out the lesson that probably most formatively impacted Arnie young in his life to become a good acceptor of reality was he was trying to become an artist. He was a fine artist. And he decided he wanted to do that as a living, not on the side. He knew he could be an amateur artist
他快91岁了。事实证明，对阿尼年轻时的生活产生最决定性影响，让他成为现实的良好接受者的教训是，他曾试图成为一名艺术家。他是一位美术艺术家。他决定以这个为生，而不是当副业。他知道自己可以成为一名业余艺术家
and make a good living, doing other kinds of things. But no, he wanted to walk his talk and do his rather avant-garde kind of art. And he was struggling and having a hard time. And then he said an interesting thing. He said, and suddenly I realized something that made all the difference.
并通过做其他事情谋生。但没有，他想言行一致，创作他那种相对前卫的艺术。他一直在挣扎，过得很艰难。然后他说了一件有趣的事。他说，突然我意识到了一件有所改变的事情。
And so, well, Arnie, what's that? He said, I realize if I'm going to be an artist, I just have to accept that I'm going to be poor for the rest of my life. He said, and once I accepted that, it was really quite easy. And I said, how old are you? He said, oh, early 30s? I said, whoa. So now, so he's got some precedent there.
那么，阿尼，那是什么？他说，我意识到如果我要成为一名艺术家，我必须接受余生都会贫穷的事实。他说，一旦我接受了这一点，事情就变得相当简单了。我说，你多大了？他说，哦，30岁出头？我说，哇。所以现在，他在那里有一些先例。
He made a big realization, and it became easy. I mean, you know, hand-a-mouth and struggling and all kinds of things, but easy in that he's not fighting it. So now, you know, he lives in an artist's installation. Some many years ago, a group of artists got together with a patron and found an old warehouse and some divided the warehouse into studio apartments. And he's been there for decades, you know, living in very Spartan digs, sitting in his wheelchair, barely able to move. He sleeps about 17 hours a day now because his body is failing. But when you walk into the room and see him and go,
他有了重大的认识，事情变得简单了。我的意思是，你知道，勉强度日、挣扎和各种各样的事情，但简单在于他没有抗争。所以现在，你知道，他住在艺术家装置中。多年前，一群艺术家与一位赞助人聚在一起，找到了一个旧仓库，并将仓库划分成工作室公寓。他在那里住了几十年，你知道，住在非常简陋的居所里，坐在轮椅上，几乎无法移动。他现在每天睡大约17个小时，因为他的身体正在衰竭。但当你走进房间看到他并问，
How's it going? He goes, oh, have you ever read Balzac? He's amazing. Come over here. And he's been reading Balzac. And so he's reading, and he's writing his memoir. He's using a big magnifying glass so that he can see the keyboard. What he's doing is leaning all the way in, being fully available to the life that is in front of him and wasting no energy whatsoever mourning what's been lost. It's stunning. Radical acceptance is the foundation for all the pursuits that make life meaningful. It is not about settling or being less ambitious or giving up. Rather, it is about approaching life with clear eyes. When we stop fighting what we cannot change, it opens up avenues for real change.
最近怎么样？他说，哦，你读过巴尔扎克吗？他太棒了。过来这里。他一直在读巴尔扎克。所以他在读书，他在写回忆录。他用一个大放大镜，以便能看到键盘。他正在做的是全身心投入，完全向眼前的生活开放，不浪费任何精力去哀悼失去的东西。这太震撼了。彻底接受是让生活变得有意义的所有追求的基础。这不是妥协或降低雄心或放弃。相反，它是以清醒的眼睛对待生活。当我们停止抗争我们无法改变的事物时，它就为真正的改变开辟了道路。
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Do you have questions or comments about how to live a more meaningful life? Have you ever felt stuck and then found a way forward? If you have a personal story you'd be willing to share with the Hidden Brain audience, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty. Email the audio file to us using the email address,
你正在收听的是隐藏的大脑。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这是隐藏的大脑。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。关于如何过上有意义的生活，你有什么问题或评论吗？你是否曾感到陷入困境，然后找到了前进的方法？如果你有一个愿意与隐藏的大脑听众分享的个人故事，请找一个非常安静的房间，在你的手机上录制语音备忘录。两到三分钟就足够了。使用电子邮件地址将音频文件发送给我们，
Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, stuck. Again, that email address is Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Purpose. connection, meaning, resilience. These qualities don't always come easily. At Stanford University, Dave Evans studies design thinking. He says that thinking like a designer can help us cultivate those qualities.
Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org。使用主题行，stuck。再次，该电子邮件地址是Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org。目标。联系。意义。韧性。这些品质并不总是轻易获得的。在斯坦福大学，戴夫·埃文斯研究设计思维。他说，像设计师一样思考可以帮助我们培养这些品质。
But before we can figure out how to implement principles of design thinking in our lives, we need to radically accept our lives as they actually are. Along with Bill Burnett, Dave is co-author of How to Live a Meaningful Life, using design thinking to unlock purpose, joy, and flow every day. Dave, we've talked about how radical acceptance is the foundation of design thinking. I want to talk now about some of the techniques that can help us design our lives. Many years ago, you were driving up from Santa Cruz to San Francisco. It was an ordinary Thursday afternoon, but something happened that day that was most unusual.
但在此之前，要想弄清楚如何在生活中贯彻设计思维的原则，我们需要彻底接受生活的本然面目。与比尔·伯内特（Bill Burnett）一起，戴夫是《如何过上有意义的生活》（How to Live a Meaningful Life）的合著者，该书旨在利用设计思维每天解锁目标、快乐和心流。戴夫，我们之前探讨过，彻底接受是设计思维的基础。现在我想谈谈一些能帮我们设计人生的技术。很多年前，你从圣克鲁斯驾车前往旧金山。那是一个普通的周四下午，但那天发生了一件极不寻常的事。
Tell me what happened. Well, the sun went down. And, of course, we think that happens most days, but some days it happens differently. And this was one of those sunsets. I'm driving along Highway 1, the famous California Coastal Highway, near Half Moon Bay. And the sun was going down, and it was drop, dead, knock your eyes out, gorgeous, in a stunningly cosmic way. I've seen so many gorgeous sunsets. My home in Santa Cruz is actually on the water.
告诉我发生了什么。嗯，太阳下山了。当然，我们觉得这大部分日子都会发生，但有些日子情况不同。这就是其中一个日落。我正开着车行驶在1号公路上，那是著名的加州海岸公路，靠近半月湾。当时太阳正在下落，那种美简直令人窒息、目眩神迷，具有一种惊人的宇宙美感。我见过太多美丽的日落。我在圣克鲁斯的家其实就临海。
I get to see the sunset almost every day. But this one was really blow your brains out. amazing, so much so that I had to stop the car. I stopped the car, I got out of the car, and then everybody else, the entire highway stopped. All these people lined up on the side of the road standing there gawking at the sunset for about seven minutes until it slipped below the waves. And then literally a moment after that last little bit of light went below the horizon, you heard this cry, this whoa! I mean, the sudden, you know, community, of sunset appreciators
我几乎每天都能看到日落。但这一次真的是美得惊天动地，以至于我不得不把车停下来。我停下车，下了车，然后其他所有人，整条公路上的人都停了下来。所有这些人都在路边排成一排，站在那里盯着日落看大约七分钟，直到它滑入波浪之下。就在最后一丝光亮没入地平线后的一瞬间，你听到了这样的欢呼声，这种“哇！”的声音。我是说，突然之间，你知道的，这个由日落欣赏者组成的社群
all start looking at each other, hooping and hollering, you know, and the couple, about 50 or at the week, come running down because you have to have a shared experience. You can't do this by yourself.
开始互相看着，欢呼雀跃，你知道的，还有大约50岁左右的一对夫妇跑过来，因为你必须有共同的经历。你无法独自完成这件事。
Like, oh my God, oh my God, did you see that? Like, oh, yes, I totally saw that. We actually like exchange names and phone numbers.
就像，“哦天哪，哦天哪，你看到了吗？”就像，“哦，是的，我完全看到了。”我们甚至还交换了姓名和电话号码。
Once a year, we're going to call each other back and remember the day. You know, it was literally this, you know, astonishing thing. You know, then you get back in the car
一年一次，我们要给对方回电话，纪念这一天。你知道的，字面意思上，这就是一件令人惊奇的事情。然后你重新回到车里
and like, whoa, what was that? So, yeah, that was a pretty cool. sunset. You see that radical acceptance is a prerequisite to finding wonder in our lives. How so, Dave? You know, wonder comes from curiosity and mystery. The apex of the curious experience is to apply curiosity to something we can't fully understand, of which there are many. Even if we later will understand the science behind it, that doesn't take all the quality away. Even on a sunset, I mean,
然后心想，“哇，那是什么？”所以，是的，那是个相当酷的日落。你看，彻底接受是我们在生活中寻找惊奇感的前提。为什么会这样，戴夫？你知道，惊奇感来自于好奇心和神秘感。好奇体验的顶峰是将好奇心应用于我们无法完全理解的事物，而这类事物有很多。即使我们日后会理解背后的科学原理，这也不会夺走它的全部特质。即使是在日落时分，我是说，
I can go to, you know, a light specialist in the physics department. He'll explain to me exactly why the sunset works the way it does. Or as the old Noel Stozy song says, you know, a scientist may tell you how night turns in today. But it can never take the wonder away. So if I allow the wonder of something to get to me and I let my curiosity follow into it without suddenly trying to diagnose and, you know, deconstruct the thing technically, I allow myself to have this deeper experience of wonder, of awe. What does that really mean?
我可以去找物理系的某个光学专家。他会向我准确解释日落为什么会以这种方式发生。或者就像诺埃尔·斯托齐（Noel Stozy）的老歌里唱的那样，科学家可能会告诉你黑夜是如何变成白天的。但它永远无法带走那种惊奇感。因此，如果我允许某事物的惊奇感触动我，并让我的好奇心深入其中，而不是突然试图去分析和技术性地解构它，我就允许自己获得这种更深层次的惊奇感和敬畏感。这到底意味着什么？
It means there's something bigger than me going on. What Maslow finally realized was a higher experience, the self-actualization, which is self-transcendency. What was going on in that amazing sunset was a whole bunch of people were having a transcendent moment, and as it was shared, we became even more human with one another. So that's what wonder does. It really leans us full.
这意味着有某种比我更伟大的事物正在发生。马斯洛最终意识到这是一种更高的体验，即自我实现，也就是自我超越。那个惊人的日落中发生的事情是，一大群人正在经历一个超越时刻，由于它是共享的，我们彼此之间变得更具人性。这就是惊奇感的作用。它确实让我们完全倾向于
into our humanness. And of course, that sunset was amazing. It was beautiful. It was so beautiful that everyone jumped out of their cars. But the truth is that there are probably amazing and beautiful things happening all the time that we're just passing by without noticing. In fact, all sunsets are beautiful and all sunrises are beautiful. In fact, every day is beautiful if we stop to admire the beauty.
我们的人性。当然，那个日落非常惊艳。它太美了，以至于每个人都跳出了汽车。但事实是，可能一直都有惊人且美好的事物在发生，而我们只是与之擦肩而过却没有注意到。事实上，所有的日落都很美，所有的日出都很美。事实上，如果我们停下来欣赏这种美，每一天都是美丽的。
It really is about paying attention. A philosopher will tell you that the mere fact that anything exists at all is actually kind of stunning. We're just so used to it. You know, I'm sitting here at my desk and I have a couple of pieces of paper, you know, and that paper, oh, my God. I mean, that used to be a tree, and that tree used to be a seed. And I'm like, holy cow. I mean, everything is amazing if you just haven't forgotten it. So we all live in an enchanted reality, but we've just gotten so accustomed to it.
这确实关乎注意力。哲学家会告诉你，任何事物存在的本身这个事实其实就相当震撼。我们只是太习惯了。你知道，我正坐在这里的桌子旁，我手里有几张纸，你知道的，那张纸，哦天哪。我的意思是，那曾经是一棵树，而那棵树曾经是一粒种子。我就像，天哪。我的意思是，如果你没有忘记它，一切都是神奇的。所以我们都生活在一个被施了魔法的现实中，但我们已经对它习以为常了。
We've turned the enchantment off. Tell me about a student of yours whom you called Stina, who was trying to fit two parts of her life that were not coming together. So we offer office hours to our students, because, of course, there's always a conversation going on about what do I do of my life, and that's true for my clients and true for everybody. And Stina came, and she started describing a problem that I thought I'd heard before. She said, I've gone through the university,
我们把魔法关掉了。跟我讲讲你的一个学生，你叫她斯蒂娜（Stina），她当时正试图将她生活中两个无法融合的部分契合在一起。所以我们为学生提供办公时间，因为当然，关于“我的人生要做什么”的讨论一直在进行，这对我辅导的客户来说是这样，对每个人来说也是如此。斯蒂娜来了，她开始描述一个我以为我以前听过的问题。她说，我读完了大学，
and I've majored in chemistry, and I got all A's like my parents wanted me to, and I've got admitted to both Yale and Harvard Medical Schools, except I don't want to go to medical school. I said, what's the problem? She said, well, I'm also a pianist, and I love music, and my parents didn't want me to study music because it's not an important enough thing, but I care about it, so I didn't major in music while I was here
主修化学，拿到了父母希望的所有全A成绩，我被耶鲁大学和哈佛大学医学院同时录取了，只是我不想去医学院。我问，问题是什么？她说，嗯，我还是一位钢琴家，我热爱音乐，而我的父母不想让我学音乐，因为它不够重要，但我很在乎它，所以我在这里时没有主修音乐
to honor my parents, but I kept my music going, and little do they know that I also applied to Juilliard School of Music, and I've been admitted to get a master's of arts in piano performance. And so I've got a problem. And I said, oh, so your problem is how do you tell your parents you don't want to be a doctor? She says, no, no, no, that's not my problem. Well, what's your problem? Well, my problem is, how do I tell my boyfriend?
为了尊崇父母，但我一直在坚持弹钢琴，他们不知道的是，我还申请了茱莉亚音乐学院（Juilliard School of Music），并且已经被录取去攻读钢琴演奏艺术硕士学位。所以，我遇到了一个问题。我说，哦，所以你的问题是怎么告诉父母你不想当医生？她说，不，不，不，这不是我的问题。好吧，你的问题是什么？嗯，我的问题是，我该怎么告诉我的男朋友？
I know what the piano requires, and it requires everything I've got. I don't think I can be in love with the piano. and a man at the same time. So I'm going to break up with my boyfriend, and I don't think he's going to understand. And I went, oh, that's a different problem. So here we had a person who really had three things going on. I've got the doctor and my parents' expectations.
我知道钢琴需要什么，它需要我拥有的一切。我觉得我无法同时爱上钢琴和一个男人。所以我要和男友分手，而且我觉得他不会理解。我当时想，哦，那是另一个问题。所以在这里，我们有一个人内心确实同时在进行三件事。我有医生的身份以及父母的期望。
I've got the artist and my relationship with the piano. And then I've got the is my piano psyche and my romantic psyche able to co-reside. What did you choose to do? To my knowledge, she went to Julia. and she told me she was going to break up with a boyfriend. How that went, I don't know. And whether or not she eventually got to the place
我有艺术家的身份以及我与钢琴的关系。然后我遇到了我的钢琴心智与我的浪漫心智是否能够共存的问题。你选择怎么做？据我所知，她去了茱莉亚音乐学院，并且她告诉我她要和男友分手。进展如何，我不得而知。以及她最终是否达到了那个状态——
where she believed that she could both be in relationship with the piano and a person, I didn't learn. But I've always been incredibly respectful of Stephen's story because the honesty she had with herself, I rarely find. Now, we often see this in the lives of some people. You work with Steve Jobs at Apple, and, you know, famously, you know, his personal life was nothing to write home about, but in some ways, perhaps that was the price that he and the
在那里她相信自己既能与钢琴保持联系，又能与人建立关系，我没有去了解。但我一直对斯蒂娜的故事怀有无比的敬意，因为她对自己的诚实是我很少见到的。现在，我们在某些人的生活中经常看到这一点。你与苹果公司的史蒂夫·乔布斯（Steve Jobs）共事过，众所周知，他的个人生活乏善可陈，但在某些方面，也许那是他和周围人付出的代价，为了让他完成他在工作中取得的成就。
people around him were paying for him to accomplish what he did at work. Talk about the idea that in some ways a well-designed life has a certain direction to it. It feels cohesive. Yeah, we call it coherency. It's one of the places you can experience meaning-making, and we describe coherence, a coherent person, as one for whom, who I am, what I'm doing, and what I believe, in are lined up and interconnected. So one of the first steps in becoming a coherent person is articulating what those things actually mean to you. And we have an exercise of that called the compass exercise that helps people get a handle on that. And living more coherently is pretty much a prerequisite to living meaningfully because if I'm not coherent, if I'm not really
谈谈这样一种观点：在某种程度上，一个精心设计的人生有着某种方向性。它感觉是连贯的。是的，我们称之为连贯性。这是你能体验到意义构建的地方之一，我们这样描述连贯性，一个连贯的人是指这样的人：他是谁，他在做什么，以及他的信念，这三者是排成一线且相互关联的。因此，成为一个连贯的人的第一步，是明确这些事情对你而言到底意味着什么。我们为此有一个名为罗盘练习的练习，能帮助人们掌控这一点。而且，过上更连贯的生活几乎是过上有意义生活的前提，因为如果我不连贯，如果我真的没有
acting like Dave, if you're really not acting like Shanker, then nothing's going to work. I'm wondering if you can talk a little bit about this compass exercise that you mentioned just now, Dave. How can we get our lives so that who I am, what I do, all of these things are aligned? Well, we have you write three short little pieces of work. You know, we look at it real high, pretty high, and down to the ground. We just have three levels of pretty much the same thing. So the life view is a page, a page and a half of your answer to the questions. what are your thoughts, what are your ideas about the most important things?
表现得像戴夫，如果你真的没有表现得像尚卡尔，那么什么都不会奏效。我想知道你是否能多谈谈你刚才提到的这个罗盘练习，戴夫？我们如何才能让我们的生活达到这样的状态：我是谁，我做什么，所有这些事情都是一致的？好吧，我们让你写三篇短短的小作品。你知道的，我们从非常宏观、相当宏观以及落实到地面的视角来审视它。我们只是在三个层面上做差不多的事情。因此，人生观就是回答这些问题的一页到一页半的内容：你的想法是什么，你对最重要的事情有什么看法？
I mean, what is life for? What does it mean to be a person? Is there really love? Is there a God? Whatever you think the most important questions that define reality are, what are your thoughts about that? That's your life view or what used to be called your worldview. Next, we have your work view.
我是说，生活是为了什么？做一个人意味着什么？真的有爱吗？有上帝吗？无论你认为定义现实的最重要的问题是什么，你对此有什么看法？这就是你的人生观，或者以前被称为你的世界观。接下来，我们有你的工作观。
Now, for most people, the overwhelmingly largest expression of your human energy is what we call work, whether it's what you do for money or a living, but your particular engagement. your role in the human adventure, how you're spending your time during the day. That is the largest single chunk of the lived experience. You spend more time doing that than cooking and eating, more time doing that than raising kids, more time doing that than, you know, making love to your spouse, whatever it is. The work thing is the big dog always has been, probably always will be, AI notwithstanding. So we say, what's your work for, meaning what do you believe work is for?
现在，对大多数人来说，人类能量绝大部分最大规模的表达就是我们所说的工作，无论是你为了赚钱或谋生而做的事情，还是你特定的投入。你在人类冒险历程中所扮演的角色，你在白天是如何度过时间的。这是生活体验中最大单一板块。你花在这上面的时间多于做饭和吃饭，多于养育孩子，多于和你的配偶做爱，无论那是什么。工作这件事一直是重中之重，过去是，可能将来也一直是，尽管人工智能已经出现。所以我们说，你的工作是为了什么，意思是相信工作是为了什么？
Is it to just keep you busy? Is it to make a living? Is it to make a world a better place? is it the place where community can be experienced as we collaborate. What are your thoughts about what good work really means to you? So what does life mean to you? What does work mean to you? Then the last question is just, what's your current story?
它是为了让你保持忙碌吗？是为了谋生吗？是为了让世界变得更美好吗？还是在我们合作时能够体验到社群的地方？对于好的工作对你而言究竟意味着什么，你有什么看法？所以生活对你意味着什么？工作对你意味着什么？然后最后一个问题仅仅是，你目前的故事是什么？
You know, if you've just got an elevator ride, it got a minute or two to tell somebody, what's currently going on with you? What's the current caption, the long caption of your story? So when you take these three little narratives, my view of life, my view of work, my view of my present experience of being me, in those three things a surprisingly good description of who you currently are
你知道的，如果你刚坐上电梯，只有一两分钟时间告诉别人，你目前正在经历什么？当前的故事标题是什么，你故事的长标题是什么？所以，当你把这三个小叙事——我对生活的看法、我对工作的看法、我对当前身为自己的体验的看法——结合在这三件事中时，你会发现对你目前是谁的一个出奇好的描述
and then we can take those three things and probably we can reverse engineer what we call your compass values. If I read these three things, there's no more than three pages, what values are emerging is most important to you? So those three documents
然后我们可以把这三件事拿来，也许我们可以通过逆向工程得出我们所谓的罗盘价值观。如果我阅读这三份内容（不超过三页），哪些价值观会凸显为对你最重要的？所以这三份文件
and a little list of the core values that are hiding in there is a real good starting place. I want to talk about another component to designing a meaningful life and that's the concept of flow. We've talked about this concept in the show before,
以及其中隐藏的核心价值观小列表，是一个非常好的起点。我想谈谈设计有意义生活的另一个组成部分，那就是心流的概念。我们在节目中以前讨论过这个概念，
but can you describe what psychologists mean by the term? Well, Flow, the psychology of optimal experience, was the book written over 20 years ago now by Mihai, The Well-Khawichikse and Mejai, the well-known psychologist of Flow, who, in collaboration with Martin Seligman from Pennsylvania, started the whole positive psychology movement about 20 years ago, good people doing good work,
但是你能描述一下心理学家这个词所指的意思吗？嗯，心流，即最佳体验心理学，是米哈里·契克森米哈赖（Mihaly Csikszentmihalyi）在20年多前写的一本书，米哈里是著名的心流心理学家，他与宾夕法尼亚州的马丁·塞利格曼（Martin Seligman）合作，在20年前左右开启了整个积极心理学运动，优秀的人在做优秀的工作，
and he defines Flow as the experience of full and, engagement where time stands still and so on that can occur when you're operating in the flow channel. And the flow channel is a place of experience where the task you are currently involved in and your skills to perform that task are in approximate balance. You're neither overtalented, so you're bored, nor undertalented, so you're anxious and nervous you might fail. But you're really right at the edge of your capability, which means this task is demanding. your full attention, that's the flow zone, the flow channel, and in that flow channel, you might, not necessarily, you might drop into the flow experience of suddenly finding yourself fully,
他将心流定义为完全投入的体验，时间静止等等，这可能在你处于心流通道中运作时发生。而心流通道是一个体验场所，在这里你当前参与的任务与你执行该任务的技能大致平衡。你既没有过高天赋以至于感到无聊，也没有过低天赋以至于感到焦虑和紧张可能会失败。但你真的正处于能力边缘，这意味着这项任务正在要求你全力关注，这就是心流区，心流通道，在这个心流通道中，你可能会——不一定非得如此——落入心流体验中，突然发现自己完全、
deeply engaged, time stand still, and when it's over, the whole thing seemed very satisfying. It's a really wonderful experience, sometimes called getting in the zone. Now, our thoughts on that, by the way, are, that's a great starting place, but unfortunately, the way people think of flow is they think of it at this very high level of engagement, which we refer to as apex flow, which is great. You know, like when you're having that incredible performance or writing that beautiful sonnet, that's an experience of that kind. I was in flow watching that sunset.
深深地投入，时间静止了，当它结束时，整件事显得非常满足。这真的是一种美妙的体验，有时被称为进入状态。现在，我们对此的想法是，顺便说一句，这是个绝佳的起点，但不幸的是，人们对心流的看法是将其视为极高水平的投入，我们称之为巅峰心流，这太棒了。你知道的，就像当你进行那场不可思议的表演或写出那首美丽的十四行诗时，那就是那种体验。我在看那个日落时就处于心流中。
These are apex experiences, and too many people think that's the minimum requirement for being in flow. And we're going to make a suggestion that simple flow is available much more of the time, to many more people, and we all need to access it to have more meaning. What is simple flow, Dave, and how is this contrasted with the world of transactional thinking that we are so often engaged in? Well, one of the things that's true when I'm in flow is I have to be in the present moment. I'm engaged enough. And again, the traditional definition of flow, which you've really done is you've said,
这些都是巅峰体验，太多人认为这是进入心流的最低要求。我们要提出这样一个建议：简单心流在更多的时间里对更多的人是可及的，我们所有人都需要接触它以获得更多意义。什么是简单心流，戴夫，这与我们经常参与的交易思维世界有何对照？嗯，当我处于心流中时，有一件事是真实的，那就是我必须置身于当下。我的投入度足够高。再说一次，传统的心流定义，你真正做的事情是你说过——
I need to find a task that demands so much of me, it will suck all of my attention and in so doing, prevent me from being distracted by other things, and that will allow me to fully engage the present moment. So what I've really done is I've outsourced my attention to the challenge of my task, and that can work. But what we're saying is, look, you're an autonomous being. You've got from free will here. You've got some power.
我需要找到一项对我有极高要求的任务，它能吸干我的所有注意力，从而阻止我被其他事情分心，并让我能够完全投入到当下。所以实际上我所做的，是将我的注意力外包给任务的挑战，这确实管用。但我们的意思是，听着，你是一个独立的个体。这里你有自由意志。你拥有一些力量。
You can actually make some choices to expand the flow channel and make it what we call the simple flow channel. So let's say I'm doing a task that, frankly, doesn't require everything I can do. I'm just chopping onions to prepare for soup. I'm making soup for dinner. I'm chopping an onion. Not that hard.
你实际上可以做出一些选择来拓宽心流通道，把它变成我们所说的简单心流通道。比方说，我正在做一项坦白说并不需要我全力以赴的任务。我只是在为做汤切洋葱。我在做晚饭的汤。我在切洋葱。没那么难。
I'm a little bored doing it. But, hey, I can still be fully present in that task. So what I can do is I can choose not to let boredom come in. I can really enjoy the sharpness of the knife. I can feel the crispness of the onion pushing back. I can allow myself by choice to fully engage that experience for five or ten minutes. And I can drop into flow. by choice, I can make it more available.
我在做这件事时有点无聊。但是，嘿，我依然可以完全沉浸在这个任务中。所以能做的是，我可以选择不让无聊情绪进入。我可以好好享受刀的锋利。我可以感受到洋葱回弹的爽脆。我可以凭选择让自己完全投入到那个持续五到十分钟的体验中。我能进入心流状态。凭着选择，我能让它更容易实现。
And anytime I'm in flow, I'm in the present moment, and that's a good place to be. And of course, in contrast with the transactional world, in a flow state, you're not only thinking about the end goal. You're not thinking about this destination disease that you talked about earlier, where you're always asking, what is this going to be in the future? You're actually in the present. Yes, as it turns out, transactional thinking and the transactional world that we spend a lot of I mean, almost invariably is future-oriented about the outcome that is yet to be realized.
只要我处于心流中，我就在当下，这是一个好地方。当然，与交易世界相比，在心流状态下，你不只是在考虑最终目标。你不会去想你之前谈到的那种终点病，即你总是在问，未来这会变成什么样？你实际上是在当下。是的，事实证明，我们花了很多时间的交易性思维和交易世界——我的意思是，几乎总是面向未来，关注尚未实现的成果。
And so one of the reasons flow is an antidote to transactionality is I have to be, as soon as I start thinking about the other thing, I fall out of flow. In some ways, I'm hearing echoes of this idea in what meditation can be like, Dave. You know, people talk about meditation. Of course, you can sit cross-legged and in a quiet room with your eyes closed. but people also talk about how you can have walking meditation or talking meditation, or in your case, chopping and onion meditation, where you bring your full self to the work that you're doing.
所以，心流之所以是应对功利化的解药之一，是因为我必须——一旦我开始思考别的事情，我就会退出心流状态。戴夫，在某种程度上，我在冥想的体验中听到了这种想法的回响。你知道，人们谈论冥想。当然，你可以盘腿坐在安静的房间里，闭上眼睛；但人们也谈论你可以进行走路冥想、说话冥想，或者在你的例子中，切洋葱冥想，即你将全副身心投入到你正在做的工作中。
You're fully present. And in some ways, that's not different than sitting cross-legged in a quiet room with your eyes closed. Yes, so when we talk about this reframing of there's really two worlds out there. In fact, we actually know from neurological research, especially the research done by Lisa Miller at Columbia, that these two halves of your brain are fundamentally wired differently. what she calls the achieving brain, and there's the awakened brain, and they're quite different. The achieving brain is always working in a system, has always got a closed end outcome,
你完全活在当下。在某种程度上，这跟盘腿坐在安静房间里闭上眼睛并没有什么不同。是的，所以当我们讨论这种重新构架时，实际上存在着两个世界。事实上，我们从神经科学研究中得知，尤其是哥伦比亚大学丽莎·米勒的研究，你大脑的这两个半球在根本上有着不同的神经布线。她称之为成就大脑，还有觉醒大脑，它们截然不同。成就大脑总是在一个系统中运作，总有一个封闭的结果，
and it's going for those results. And the achieving brain is getting an awful lot of stimulation these days. The awakened brain is present to that present moment. And so the mindfulness movement, you know, these various practices, one of the things we're reminding people is don't turn those into transactions, too. a lot of people turned their practice into yet another transaction. I had a really good sit this morning. I nailed my yoga practice.
并且它在为这些结果而奋斗。如今，成就大脑正在接受大量的刺激。觉醒大脑则存在于当下。所以正念运动，你知道的，这些各种各样的实践，我们提醒人们的一点是，不要把这些也变成交易。很多人把他们的修行变成了又一次交易。我今天坐禅坐得真好。我拿捏住了我的瑜伽练习。
I had a personal best in yoga today. Okay, you just turned a practice into a performance. As opposed to realizing while you're walking along, yes, you can have a walking meditation, you can have a chopping meditation, you can have a driving meditation. You can actually be more present to the world you're in all the time is not taking a little time.
我今天的瑜伽取得了个人最好成绩。好吧，你刚刚把一种练习变成了一场表演。而不是去意识到在你散步的时候，是的，你可以进行走路冥想、切洋葱冥想、开车冥想。你实际上可以一直对你所处的世界保持更多的觉察，这并不是花一点时间
out and stocking up to go back to the real world of getting things done, it's actually living in the real world that's currently happening. We talked in the last episode about this curse of always living in the future and how many of us in some ways live so much in the future that when we finally reached the end of our lives, we discover that we have never lived in the present. I'm wondering if you have taken this idea to heart yourself, Dave. Have you actually tried to embrace the present, to embrace the becoming that you yourself always are? It really is what I'm working on right now.
抽身出来充电，然后再回到充满事务的现实世界中，而是真正生活在当前正在发生的现实世界中。我们在上一集里讨论过这种总是活在未来的诅咒，以及我们当中有多少人在某种程度上如此沉溺于未来，以至于当我们最终走到生命尽头时，才发现我们从未活在当下。戴夫，我想知道你是否把这个想法铭记在心了？你是否真的试图拥抱当下，拥抱那个你一直以来正在成为的自己？这确实是我目前正在努力的事情。
What I had to admit was one of the shifts in life we talk about in late in life is moving from Roel to Seoul. I'm no longer really identified in, you know, I'm a Stanford instructing book writing guy. That's my role in the institution of, you know, the book publishing industry or in the academic world, as opposed to simply, you know, I'm Dave Evans,
我不得不承认的是，我们在人生晚期谈到的生活转变之一，就是从角色走向灵魂。我不再真正认同于，你知道的，我是一个斯坦福的讲师、写书的家伙。那是我在机构中的角色，你知道的，在图书出版界或学术界，而不是单纯地，你知道的，我叫戴夫·埃文斯，
the grandfather of 11 delightful young people, trying to show up and be present to what's currently happening. So moving out of a role-based life into more of a soul-based life means I'm trying to drop all that production-based identity. And I've got to be honest with you, it's so much harder than I thought. This growing up thing, we'd never get it done.
我是11个可爱年轻人的祖父，努力去展现自我，并对当前发生的事情保持觉察。因此，从一个基于角色的生活转变为更多基于灵魂的生活，意味着我正试图抛弃所有基于产出的身份认同。老实说，这比我想象的要难得多。成长这件事，我们永远也做不完。
The concept of radical acceptance is radical. The reason so many of us get defensive about our situation or beat ourselves up over our failures is because acceptance can be really painful. It's awful to realize we are not as far along in our careers as we would like to be. It's painful to acknowledge our relationships are not in a good place. It can be demoralizing to contemplate a health problem
绝对接纳这个概念是彻底的。我们之所以有那么多人对自己的处境进行防卫，或者因为失败而自我贬低，是因为接纳真的会很痛苦。意识到我们在职业生涯中没有取得预期的进展，这种感觉很糟糕。承认我们的关系一团糟是痛苦的。思考一个健康问题可能会让人丧失斗志
that just will not go away. That's where patience comes in. If moving forward requires us to first accept where we are, It's patience that allows us to take that first crucial step. The psychologist Sarah Schnitker once told me a story about a time her patience was sorely tested. Sarah is Christian, and she loves singing in church. But some time ago, she got some unwelcome feedback. The church I was going to at the time, they had done kind of an all-church survey,
那个问题就是挥之不去。这就是耐心发挥作用的地方。如果向前迈进要求我们首先接纳我们所在的位置，正是耐心让我们能够迈出那至关重要的第一步。心理学家莎拉·施尼特克曾给我讲过一个关于她的耐心受到严峻考验的故事。莎拉是个基督徒，她喜欢在教堂唱歌。但不久前，她收到了一些不受欢迎的反馈。我当时去的那个教堂，他们做了一项全教堂的调查，
I think, just to get data on kind of how the church was meeting the needs of its congregants. ways they could improve. And I assume that someone must have complained about my singing voice, being loud and distracting. And so the pastor of this church had met and asked me, hey, would you be willing to sing more quietly? And at the time I said, hey, I don't actually think that's a fair thing to ask me. And they kept telling me that I should just be quiet for the sake of others, that singing was kind of this freedom I should give up. And it was very emotional. I was crying. It was very deeply hurt. This is like one of my most vulnerable things I do is come and try to express how much I'm grateful for the blessings in life. And the pastor basically told me, you're not welcome here.
我想，只是为了收集关于教堂如何满足会众需求的数据，以及可以改进的地方。我猜一定有人抱怨我的歌声又响亮又让人分心。所以这个教堂的牧师就跟我见了面，问我：嘿，你愿意唱得轻一点吗？当时我说，嘿，我觉得这对我提出这种要求并不公平。他们一直告诉我，为了其他人我应该安静一点，唱歌是那种我应该放弃的自由。这非常情绪化。我在哭。我受到了深深的伤害。这就像我做过的最脆弱的事情之一，就是来表达我对生活中福分的感激之情。而牧师基本上告诉我，这里不欢迎你
as you are. And this was so incredibly painful. Sarah experienced this feedback as a deep existential crisis. She felt rejected by a group that was supposed to embrace her with acceptance. Angry thoughts bubbled up inside her. If someone had a problem with her singing, maybe they should attend a different service. Wasn't the whole point of church to celebrate faith?
以你本来的样子。这实在是太痛苦了。莎拉将这条反馈体验为一场深刻的存在主义危机。她感到被一个本该张开双臂接纳她的群体所拒绝。愤怒的想法在她心中翻腾。如果有人对她的歌声有意见，或许他们应该去参加别的礼拜。教堂的全部意义难道不是庆祝信仰吗？
How could her pastor be telling her to turn down the volume of her worship? But rather than act with haste, she decided to practice what her own research into the value of patients had taught her. She asked herself what her faith meant to her. She pondered why she felt so hurt. She gave herself time to think, to feel, to sit. I just took the time to really heal from that experience. Kind of tried to practice my patience, let myself heal. But then decided, you know what, I'm going to go to go.
牧师怎么能叫她把敬拜的音量调低呢？但她没有草率行事，而是决定践行她自己关于耐心价值的研究教给她的东西。她问自己她的信仰对她意味着什么。她琢磨为什么自己会觉得这么受伤。她给自己时间去思考、去感受、去沉淀。我只是花了时间真正从那段经历中疗愈。算是试着践行我的耐心，让自己疗愈。但随后决定，你知道吗，我要去找找
find a different faith community to be a part of and went to a different type of church that had a different style of worship. But to this day, sing very loudly. And I'm very glad I gave myself the time to be patient with my own healing from that experience instead of rushing back in because it's such a rich source of meaning and support that knowing God loves me and also that other people in my church community also love me and love my singing is really, really important. We all have moments in our lives when we know we need to exercise patience. But knowing something and actually doing it are two different things. When we come back, Sarah Schnitker shares what she has learned about putting patience into practice.
找一个不同的信仰社团加入，并去了一家有着不同敬拜风格的不同类型的教堂。但直到今天，我唱歌声音还是很大。我非常庆幸自己给了自己时间，对自己的那段经历疗愈保持耐心，而不是急着冲回去，因为这是一个如此丰富的意义和支持源泉，知道上帝爱我，并且知道我教堂社团里的其他人也爱我、爱我的歌声，这真的是非常非常重要。我们生活中都有这样的时刻，我们知道自己需要保持耐心。但知道一回事，真正做到又是另一回事。回来后，莎拉·施尼特克将分享她关于将耐心付诸实践的心得。
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. At Baylor University, psychologist Sarah Schnitker studies patients, its benefits, its costs, and how to harness this important skill. She recently joined us for a conversation titled The Practice of Patience. Today, she's back to respond to your questions and stories in our popular segment, your questions answered. Sarah Schnitker, welcome to Hidden Brain. Hi, Shankar. Thanks for having me back. Sarah, I'd like to start by asking you to share a story that's set in a place where a lot of people can find that patience is tested.
你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在贝勒大学，心理学家莎拉·施尼特克研究耐心，它的益处、它的代价，以及如何驾驭这项重要的技能。她最近加入我们的访谈，主题是《耐心的实践》。今天她重返节目，在我们的热门环节“你的问题解答”中回答你们的问题和故事。莎拉·施尼特克，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。嗨，尚卡尔。谢谢你邀请我回来。莎拉，我想先请你分享一个故事，背景设定在很多人发现耐心受到考验的地方。
I understand that when you got married, you and your husband bought annual passes to Disneyland, but when you got to the, quote, happiest place on Earth, you noticed something quite different than what you expected. Tell me what you saw. Yes, we love Disneyland, and like many, do feel it's one of the happiest places you can be in the world. But we got there and quickly noticed lots of people were not happy. Children in particular were often crying and whining. You saw other couples maybe getting frustrated with each other and with the weight. And really, it struck me that Disneyland and other amusement parks are just an exercise and patience. You're waiting a ton of time in line for a very short experience.
据我了解，当你结婚时，你和丈夫买了两张迪士尼乐园的年票，但当你到达那个所谓的“地球上最快乐的地方”时，你注意到了一些与预期截然不同的情况。告诉我你看到了什么。是的，我们喜欢迪士尼乐园，和许多人一样，确实觉得它是世界上最快乐的地方之一。但我们到了那里，很快就注意到许多人不快乐。尤其是孩子们经常哭泣和发牢骚。你会看到其他伴侣可能对彼此感到沮丧，对排队感到沮丧。真的，这让我感到迪士尼和其他游乐园只是一场关于耐心的练习。你在队伍里花了大量时间，却只换来非常短暂的体验，
maybe that only lasts a couple minutes. I wonder if it's harder to practice patients in Disneyland because our expectations are that a visit is going to be nonstop fun. And it's hard for reality to compete with that vision. Talk for a moment about how our expectations can influence our ability to practice patients, Sarah. Yes, that's a great question. And I think expectations are critical. When you find that your weight is longer,
可能只持续几分钟。我在想，在迪士尼更难保持耐心，是不是因为我们的期望是这次游玩会带来不间断的快乐？而现实很难与这种愿景相抗衡。莎拉，请谈谈我们的期望如何影响我们保持耐力的能力。是的，这是一个好问题。我认为期望至关重要。当你发现你的等待时间比预期更长，
than you had anticipated, or even the fact that you have to wait at all or have sore feet toward the end of the day as you're walking around the amusement park, this can start to violate your expectations and you start to feel this impatient emotion, that things should be different. And I find this objectionable because it's different than what I hoped. And so we see that in those circumstances, that's when impatient starts to become a struggle and when we really need to practice our patients. You say there are different types of patients. One has to do with patients in our personal relationships.
甚至是你根本不得不等待，或者在游乐园里走了一整天后脚底酸痛，这开始违背你的期望，你开始感受到这种不耐烦的情绪，觉得事情本该不同。我发现这令人反感，因为它与我所希望的不同。所以我们看到，在这些情况下，不耐烦开始成为一种挣扎，而这正是我们需要练习耐心的时候。你说过有不同类型的耐心。一种与我们的人际关系中的耐心有关。
I'd like to share a message we received about that from a listener named Lindsay. I find that in my role in my job as a pediatric physical therapist, I have an exceptional amount of patients. I work with a lot of young children who have developmental disabilities and find it easier or just, part of my job to be patient as I work with them on various skills and activities. But when I come home, sometimes I have very, very limited patients when I'm interacting with my husband or my dog, when messes have been left out and it seems like it could have been
我想分享一位听众琳赛发来的关于这方面的留言。我发现在我作为儿科物理治疗师的工作角色中，我有异常多的耐心。我和许多有发育障碍的幼儿一起工作，在和他们一起进行各种技能和活动时，保持耐心对我来说更容易，或者说只是我工作的一部分。但当我回到家时，有时我的耐心非常非常有限，当我与丈夫或小狗互动时，当家里留下一团乱七八糟的杂物，而这些本来似乎
attended to by my husband. But I end up taking on that responsibility. I have very limited patients when it comes to my relationships with other people. This is such an acute observation, Sarah. Lots of us are called to practice patients in our professional lives and we deliver. But then when we come home, we don't extend the same grace to the people in our personal lives. Why do you think this is? Yes, I think Lindsay really picks up such an interesting tension for many of us.
应该由我丈夫来处理。但我最终还是承担起了那个责任。在处理与其他人的关系时，我的耐心非常有限。这是一个非常敏锐的观察，莎拉。我们许多人都被要求在职业生涯中保持耐心并且我们做到了。但当我们回到家时，我们并没有对我们个人生活中的人给予同样的宽容。你认为这是为什么？是的，我认为琳赛确实指出了对我们许多人来说非常有趣的一种张力。
I think part of this has to do with the expectations that we have, that. when we go to work, we expect it will feel like work and could be difficult. And that, especially if you're working with children, that we have expectations that they won't be able to do everything quickly. But then when it comes to our own families, when we get home, I think there's two things working against us. First, we are tired at the end of the day, right? We've been practicing our patients and are starting to lose our motivation to continue. But then the second thing is that we might have higher expectations for our family members. And when we get home, we also expect it should be time to relax, that now I can stop having to feel like I'm working
我认为这部分与我们的期望有关，那就是当我们去上班时，我们期望它会像工作一样，而且可能会很艰难。并且，特别是如果你和孩子们一起工作，我们对他们不能快速完成所有事情是有心理准备的。但当谈到我们自己的家庭时，当我们回到家时，我认为有两件事在对我们起反作用。首先，我们在一天结束时累了，对吧？我们一直在练习耐心，开始失去继续下去的动力。但第二件事是，我们可能对家庭成员有更高的期望。当我们回到家时，我们也期望这应该是放松的时间，现在我可以不用再觉得自己像在工作了，
and instead move into the relaxation portion of my day. But that's often not the case. That can be when maybe the second shift begins. And there's a lot of new work to do. So Lindsay's comment also reminds me of a second type of patients that you talk about, and this is the patients required to deal with mundane problems, so chores and traffic jams and lost phones. And I'm wondering whether these moments become especially tedious because of the sheer number of them that we have to deal with on a daily basis? I think that definitely would be the case.
而是转入我一天的放松部分。但通常情况并非如此。那往往是第二班岗开始的时候。还有很多新的工作要做。所以琳赛的评论也让我想起了你谈到的第二种耐心，这是应对琐碎问题所需的耐心，也就是家务、交通堵塞和丢失的手机。我想知道，这些时刻是否因为我们每天必须应对的数量极其庞大而变得格外烦人？我想情况绝对是这样的。
I think it's a really interesting question of whether it gets more and more difficult as we encounter more and more of these daily hassles. But I think what we know from other research studies on self-regulation and emotion regulation is that when the pressures accumulate, we don't always have the resources available to meet those pressures. And so there might be an optimal level of daily frustrations that will help us build patients but not fall prey to impatience. And it might be once we get past that optimal level, we start to just kind of deteriorate into
我觉得这是一个非常有趣的问题，即当我们遇到越来越多的日常烦恼时，它是否会变得越来越困难。但我认为我们从关于自我调节和情绪调节的其他研究中得知，当压力累积时，我们并不总是有足够的资源来应对这些压力。因此，可能存在一个日常挫折的最佳水平，它能帮我们建立耐心，而不会沦为不耐烦。并且一旦我们超过了这个最佳水平，我们可能就会开始退化为
impatience and just struggle to get out of it. You also highlight a third type of patients. It has to do with setbacks that we face at work in our relationships or with our health. A listener named Vic Rodin with this note, I was diagnosed with multiple sclerosis in 2019. Since then, I've seen myself become a shadow of what I used to be. I was approaching a black belt in the martial art I loved. I used to bike 20 miles on a whim. I had an extensive vocabulary.
不耐烦并极力想要摆脱它。你还强调了第三种耐心。它与我们在工作、人际关系或健康方面面临的挫折有关。一位名叫维克·罗丹的听众留下了这样一条信息：我在2019年被诊断出患有多发性硬化症。从那以后，我发现自己变成了过去的影子。我曾一度接近我热爱的武术黑带。我曾经心血来潮就能骑行20英里。我曾拥有丰富的词汇量。
These days, I have tremors on my right side, need to think of every step I take. I also have balance issues. Vic has a question for you, Sarah. I considered myself to be a very patient person. Is it possible to become even more patient than you were before? And what recommendations do you have for those who go through a drastic, uninvited change. What would you say, Sarah? Well, I think the first thing I would say is my heart goes out to Vic. It sounds like this has
这些日子里，我的右侧身体会颤抖，走每一步都需要思考。我还有平衡问题。维克有一个问题想问你，莎拉。我曾认为自己是一个非常有耐心的人。一个人是否有可能变得比以前更有耐心？对于那些经历痛苦、不请自来的改变的人，你有什么建议？你会说什么，莎拉？嗯，我想我要说的第一件事是我的心与维克同在。听起来这
been a really challenging diagnosis and that Vic is just dealing with a lot of changes and losses. I think it is possible to grow more and more patient. Many of us experience growth in patience over time, not always, but sometimes. And we do have data showing that. people can grow in their patients over the course of years, not just months. But I also am struck by the challenges that a diagnosis like MS can bring to a person's life. And it seems to me that part of the ability to maintain patients in this kind of circumstance would also be really selecting well goals that are still important. optimizing towards those goals and that by homing in on what is really critical, it allows you
经历了一次非常具有挑战性的诊断，维克正在应对许多变化和损失。我认为培养越来越多的耐心是有可能的。我们许多人的耐心会随着时间的推移而增长，虽然不总是这样，但有时会。我们确实有数据表明，人们的耐心可以在数年而不是仅仅数月的时间里不断增长。但我也对像多发性硬化症这样的诊断给一个人生活带来的挑战深感震撼。在我看来，在这种情况下保持耐力的能力的一部分，也将是很好地选择那些仍然重要的目标，向这些目标进行优化，并且通过聚焦于真正关键的事情，它能让你
to keep your patience and not to become so dysregulated by all the things that are really challenging, but to be able to focus in. And I think finding that key purpose and really selecting what it is you care about and what you're going to try to do with your more limited resources as a human is really essential for helping that patience to grow. When we come back, how to know when you are being patient or being passive. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. In our hectic world, patients can seem like a rarity.
保持耐心，不被所有极具挑战的事情搞得彻底失调，而是能够集中注意力。我认为找到那个核心目标，真正选择你真正在乎的是什么，以及作为一个有限的人类你将如何利用你更有限的资源去做事，这对于帮助耐心增长绝对是至关重要的。稍后回来，教你如何分辨自己是在保持耐心还是在消极被动。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在我们这个快节奏的世界里，耐心似乎成了稀罕物。
In certain situations, we might even see someone who's patient as passive or unambitious. At Baylor University, Sarah Schnitker argues that patience is an underestimated strength in our busy, over-scheduled lives. Sarah, we talked in our initial conversation about Martin Luther King Jr. And his struggle to find patience in practicing civil disobedience. We heard from a listener named Simon. Simon is a bassist. He's also Asian-American and the founder of an all-Asian-American rock band called The Slants. A number of years ago, I tried to file a trademark for my band's name.
在某些情况下，我们甚至会把有耐心的人看作是消极或缺乏雄心。在贝勒大学，莎拉·施尼特克（Sarah Schnitker）指出，在我们忙碌且行程满满的生活中，耐心是一种被低估的力量。莎拉，我们在最初的对话中谈到了马丁·路德·金，以及他在践行公民不服从运动时努力保持耐心的挣扎。我们听取了一位名叫西蒙的听众的分享。西蒙是一名贝斯手。他也是亚裔美国人，是一个名为“The Slants”的全亚裔美国人摇滚乐队的创始人。多年前，我曾试图为我的乐队名称申请商标。
It was denied. The USPTO or US Patent and Trademark Office said that it was disparaging to persons of Asian descent, members of my community. This was for an all-Asian ban. I appealed. I appealed it. I got thousands and thousands of people to weigh in experts, community leaders, etc. And it just didn't seem to move the needle. Long story short, it took over eight years from start to finish.
它被拒绝了。美国专利商标局（USPTO）表示，该名称对亚裔后代以及我社区的成员构成了贬低。这是一个全亚裔乐队。我进行了申诉。我提出了申诉。我让成千上万的人参与进来，包括专家、社区领袖等。但这似乎并没有起到什么作用。简而言之，从头到尾花了八年多的时间。
before we finally made it to the Supreme Court of the United States and we won in a unanimous victory. It both kind of reiterated the fact that we needed patience and we also had urgency. That is our legal process. Our legal system is a bunch of hurrying up and waiting. You rush to file. You rush to get support. You need to make these critical deadlines. But then you have to wait.
在我们最终打到美国最高法院并获得全票胜诉之前。这既重申了我们需要耐心这一事实，也表明我们同样具有紧迫感。这就是我们的法律程序。我们的法律系统就是一堆急于求成和漫长等待的结合。你急着提交文件。你急着寻求支持。你需要赶上这些关键的截止日期。但随后你必须等待。
You have to wait for the government to respond. You have to wait for courts to decide. You have to wait sometimes for hearts to change as it needed to happen in our case. So thank you for sharing a great episode with tons of great insights on it. So that's an amazing story, Sarah. What I find fascinating about it is that Simon is pointing out there are times we need to act really quickly and times we need to be really patient and we need to have both those capacities in us. Yes, Simon's story is really astounding in many ways.
你必须等待政府的回应。你必须等待法院的裁决。正如在我们这个案子里发生的那样，有时你还必须等待人心的转变。所以，谢谢你分享了一期包含大量深刻见解的精彩节目。所以这是一个了不起的故事，莎拉。令我着迷的是，西蒙指出，有时我们需要非常迅速地行动，有时我们需要极有耐心，我们需要兼具这两种能力。是的，西蒙的故事在许多方面确实令人震惊。
such a great illustration of how patience and courage work in tandem, right? He describes these moments where they had to hustle, where they had to get paperwork filed, where they had to move very, very quickly and probably have some sleepless nights to get things done. But then there were other times in this eight-year journey where they had to just wait and probably weren't getting no news and could easily become frustrated and so disheartedly. So, just heartened that others would have given up and said, oh, we'll just stop this fight. But I think he really exemplifies that patience and courage work well together and that sometimes we really do have to be fast. And so patience does not mean we're always slow, but that we have
这真是耐心与勇气如何并肩作战的一个绝佳例证，对吧？他描述了这样一些时刻：他们必须争分夺秒、必须提交文书工作、必须非常非常快地行动，可能还要熬夜来完成任务。但在八年征程的其他时候，他们只能等待，可能得不到任何消息，因而很容易感到沮丧和灰心。不过，其他人可能会选择放弃并说，哦，我们还是停止这场斗争吧，而他却深受鼓舞。但我认为他真正诠释了耐心与勇气可以完美结合，有时我们确实必须行动迅速。因此，耐心并不意味着我们总是慢吞吞的，而是意味着我们拥有
the wisdom to move slowly when it's necessary and to move quickly when it's not and to just be properly oriented to the speed at which things need to move. Simon's comment also highlights the unique challenge of exercising patients when you're dealing with a bureaucracy or a set of institutions where you have little to no control over the outcome. I'm wondering if you have insights for listeners who may be waiting to hear back about, you know, a job they applied for or for their insurance company to approve a medical procedure that they need when it feels like they're up against, you know, a huge, faceless bureaucracy. Yes, I think this is common that people describe struggles with bureaucracies
在必要时缓慢行事、在不必要时迅速行动的智慧，并且能够适度调整事情推进的速度。西蒙的评论还突显了这样一个独特的挑战：当你与官僚机构或某些机构打交道，而你对结果几乎完全无法掌控时，如何去践行耐心。我想知道你对听众有什么见解，他们可能正在等待他们申请的工作的回复，或者等待保险公司批准他们需要的医疗程序，当他们感觉自己像是碰上了庞大而冷漠的官僚机构时。是的，我认为人们将与官僚机构的斗争描述为
is more challenging than just with other individuals. We are beginning to study parents of adolescents with disabilities, and they report this as well, that they're okay, being patient with their own child, but they get really upset and really struggle when it comes to navigating all the systems that are supposed to support their child and their family. I know I experienced this struggle when I dealt with my own health issues during grad school. And it's, I think, very helpful to have a specific plan of how you're going to move forward. So you don't have to be ruminating on it. So I know for myself, I was trying to get a certain procedure to figure out what I was sick with back when I was throwing up all the time
比与其他人打交道更具挑战性，这是很常见的。我们开始研究有残疾青少年的父母，他们也报告了这一点，他们表示自己对自己的孩子有耐心是没有问题的，但当他们需要应对所有本该支持他们孩子和家庭的系统时，他们会感到非常沮丧和痛苦。我知道我在读研究生期间处理自己的健康问题时也经历过这种挣扎。而且我认为，制定一个关于你将如何继续前进的具体计划是非常有帮助的。这样你就不必为此反复思索。所以我知道，自我回到研究生时期
in grad school before I got my sick of vomiting diagnosis. And what I did is I said, okay, I'm going to set my timer every day for 803 a.m. and for 455 p.m. And I will just call with a friendly voice and see if they can get me in because that's when they would know if they had cancellations overnight or throughout the day. And this gave me a sense of control because I had a plan and I would follow through on it. I felt like this also gave me a sense of a human connection because I'd actually talked to someone and even sometimes they would express empathy, which helped. And I mean, that's a very specific instance. But I think what our research shows us is that making particular plans that tie to cues in your environment, like setting an alarm and
在我确诊经常呕吐的病因之前，为了弄清楚我到底生了什么病，我曾试图进行某项特定的检查。我当时的做法是，我对自己说，好吧，我每天在早上8点03分和下午4点55分各定一个闹钟。我会用温和的语气打电话，看看他们能不能给我安排一个位置，因为那是他们知道是否有夜间或全天取消预约名额的时间。这让我有一种掌控感，因为我有一个计划，并且我会执行到底。我觉得这也给我带来了一种人际连接感，因为我真的和某人交谈了，有时他们甚至会表达同理心，这很有帮助。我的意思是，这是一个非常具体的例子。但我认为我们的研究向我们表明，制定与环境中的线索相联系的具体计划，比如设置闹钟并在
doing something at that time can really help us to not only achieve our goals, but to be less stressed as we're doing it. I remember the famous psychologist Amos Tversky once said something along the lines of, we lose years because we're not willing to lose ours, or words to that effect. His point was that in trying to rush something, we can sometimes slow ourselves down even further. One of our listeners named Ryder had a story along these lines. some months ago, he suffered a concussion.
那个时间做某事，确实可以帮助我们不仅实现目标，还能在实现目标的过程中减少压力。我记得著名心理学家阿莫斯·特沃斯基（Amos Tversky）曾经说过类似这样的话：我们失去了岁月，因为我们不愿失去小时，或者表达类似意思的话。他的观点是，在试图匆忙完成某事时，我们有时反而会让自己慢得更厉害。我们的一位听众名叫赖德（Ryder），他有一个与之相关的亲身经历。几个月前，他遭受了脑震荡。
What should have taken about a month tops to fully recover from has now been something I've been dealing with for five months because of my lack of patience. There were multiple instances where I was just like, you know, I probably shouldn't do this, like trying to play video games or get work done or just trying to get back into the gym and being active. and each time I did so, it would exacerbate my symptoms and set me back further. I feel I can relate to Ryder or Sarah.
本该最多花一个月左右完全康复的事情，现在却因为我缺乏耐心，变成了我五个月来一直在应对的问题。有好几次，我都觉得，你知道的，我大概不应该这么做，比如尝试玩电子游戏、完成工作，或者只是试图重新去健身房恢复活跃。而每次我这样做时，都会加剧我的症状，让我恢复得更慢。我觉得我能与赖德产生共鸣，莎拉。
Talk about this idea that rushing around can sometimes slow us down. Yeah, I resonate with Ryder many times in my life. And still to this day as I kind of cope with my own health problems of when to push, when to not push. You know, when he was speaking, I was just thinking of, I think it's in the military, they have the phrase, slow is smooth, smooth as fast, that allowing things to take their time they really need and not pushing is just so essential in nature and in our bodies and that we often lose sight of the big picture goal and get caught up
谈谈这种“仓促行事有时反而会让我们慢下来”的观点。是的，在我生活中的很多时候，我都能对赖德感同身受。直到今天，当我应对何时该推进、何时该克制自己的健康问题时，依然如此。你知道，当他说话时，我脑海里浮现出军队里的一句话：慢就是稳，稳就是快。允许事情按照它们真正需要的时间去推进，而不去勉强，这在自然界和我们的身体中是如此重要，而我们经常会忽视宏观的大局目标，陷入
in the moment, which is what I heard coming through from Ryder just a little bit is I really just want to do this now. But patience does draw in this kind of core capacity for delay of gratification and that if I can wait, I'll have the benefits in one month of being well instead of having to wait five months to still not be where I really want to be in my health. And I think it's such a temptation that we humans deal with in so many scenarios. And I think our culture so often and likes a quick comeback. And it's good to love comeback stories, but I think the quick comeback is what we really celebrate
当下之中——这正是我从赖德的话里稍微听到的一点——我真的现在就想做这件事。但耐心确实激发了这种延迟满足的核心能力，即如果我能等待，我将在一个月内收获健康的益处，而不必等待五个月却依然无法达到我在健康方面真正想要的状态。我认为这是我们人类在许多情况下都要面对的诱惑。而且我认为我们的文化总是非常喜欢快速的卷土重来。喜欢东山再起的故事固然很好，但我认为我们真正庆祝的是快速的卷土重来
instead of the slow comeback that takes the time it needs. A listener named Dave talked about an experience where he was called upon to demonstrate patients, not with himself but with a stranger. He had just started a new job and needed to get gas on the way to an important meeting. When I pulled into the gas station in Illinois, elderly woman had just pulled in in front of me and stopped in the middle of the islands.
而不是需要花费必要时间的缓慢复出。一位名叫戴夫（Dave）的听众讲述了一段经历：当时他需要表现出耐心，对象不是自己，而是一个陌生人。他刚开始一份新工作，需要在赶去参加一个重要会议的途中加满油。当我把车开进伊利诺伊州的一家加油站时，一位老妇人刚刚把车开到我前面，停在了车道中间。
She was confused on where to go or what to do, and I lost my patience, zoomed around her to a pump, got out and started pumping gas. She eventually pulled up to a pump, got out and started walking over to me. I thought she was going to admonish me for zooming around her. But instead, with tears in her eyes told me that she didn't know what to do. She had just lost her husband and had never pumped gas in her life. My heart instantly melted and I turned to her and told her I understood because I had lost my wife a year prior. I had all the patience and time in the world and walked her through the process of how to get gas. I walked away feeling very bad about losing my patients. and ever since have focused on trying to understand
她不知道该去哪里或做什么，我失去了耐心，绕过她冲向一个加油机，下车开始加油。她最终把车开到加油机旁，下车并朝我走来。我以为她是要训斥我刚才绕过她。但相反，她含着眼泪告诉我，她不知道该怎么办。她刚失去丈夫，这辈子从来没加过油。我的心瞬间融化了，我转身告诉她我能理解，因为我的妻子在一年前去世了。我有的是时间和耐心，我一步步指导她如何加油。离开时，我对自己的失去耐心感到非常糟糕。
and be empathetic to other people before losing my patience. This is such a beautiful story, Sarah. So much of the time when we are impatient with other people, it's because we don't fully understand their situation or their constraints. What an amazing story from Dave. But I think this story just tells us that for true human connection, we often have to practice a bit of patience. And that just how much we can miss in the lives of others when we're rushing and going so quickly.
从那以后，我一直专注于在失去耐心之前，试着去理解并对他人抱有同理心。这是一个多么美丽的动人故事，莎拉。很多时候，我们对他人失去耐心，是因为我们并不完全了解他们的处境或限制。戴夫分享了一个多么了不起的故事。但我认为这个故事告诉我们，为了建立真正的良好人际连接，我们往往需要练习一点耐心。当我们行色匆匆、节奏太快时，我们可能会错过他人生活中如此之多的东西。
And I think it's just profound how Dave was still, even though he started out impatient. When that bid for connection came from this woman who had lost her husband recently, Dave was able to turn around and say, oh, wait a minute. there's much more at stake here than the few minutes it might take me to get this woman sorted and help her out. And I think so often kind of in our polarized society and in our disconnected and highly lonely society, I wonder how much is really not a lack of empathy, but a lack of patience with each other that prevents us from making those true connections that are so important for our own well-being and that of others in our community. The thing that strikes me, Sarah, about Dave's account is the moment when he pulls up to the gas station
而且我认为这非常深刻：尽管戴夫一开始很不耐烦，但当这位刚失去丈夫的女士发出连接的请求时，戴夫能够回过头来说，哦，等一下。这里还有比我花几分钟帮这位女士弄好、协助她解决问题更重要的事情。我认为很多时候，在我们这个极化的社会、在我们这个缺乏联系且高度孤独的社会里，我想，这其中究竟有多少其实并非源于缺乏同理心，而是源于彼此缺乏耐心，从而阻碍了我们建立对自身和社区其他成员的福祉至关重要的那些真正连接？莎拉，戴夫的经历中最让我震撼的是他把车开到加油站
and finds this elderly lady blocking his way and he sort of zooms around her, in that moment in some ways he's come up with a fleshed-out story about why it is she's in his way and that she's incompetent in dealing with a gas station or is taking her time and is not considerate of other people. And so often I think when we find ourselves impatient with other people, we come up with a story in our own heads about why they're behaving the way they do. And of course, most of us don't get the opportunity that Dave got, which is to have his story set right. I think that is such a great point, Shankar, that we're always making stories in our heads about other people. and I'm often disappointed in myself that my story doesn't give the other person the benefit of the doubt.
发现这位老妇人挡住去路，于是他绕过她加速前行；在那一刻，他在某种程度上脑补了一个充分的理由，解释为什么她会挡住他的路，认为她在加油站表现得很笨拙，或者在磨蹭，不考虑别人的感受。很多时候，当发现自己对别人失去耐心时，我们都会在自己脑海里编造一个故事，解释他们为什么会有这种行为。当然，大多数人都不会像戴夫那样幸运，能有机会让自己的误解得到纠正。山卡尔，这是一个绝妙的观点，我们总是在脑海里编造关于别人的故事。而我常常对自己感到失望，因为我脑补的故事并没有给对方留有余地。
Right. And it's not always a compassionate story or a story that helps me think about this person as kind of a human being with dignity, how easy it is to go with a negative story. And I think one of the ways that we often train for patients is to, engage in cognitive reappraisal or training ourselves to think differently about things. And I think this brings up a great opportunity when we find ourselves impatient to say, what might be a different story than the one to recognize the story I have in the moment and to just ask myself a question, well, it would be a different story that would make me understand this scenario from a different
对。而且这并不总是一个富有同情心的故事，也不是一个能让我把这个人当作一个有尊严的人来思考的故事；沉溺于一个消极的故事是多么容易啊。我认为我们培养耐心的方法之一，就是进行认知重评，或者训练自己以不同的方式看待事物。我认为这给我们提供了一个绝佳的机会：当我们发现自己不耐烦时，去想想除了当前脑海里的故事之外，还会有什么不同的故事；去认识到自己当下脑海中的故事，然后问自己一个问题——有什么不同的故事能让我从一个不同的
perspective and partly that brings a curious orientation, which can help with patience. But I think in my experience, when I've taken the time to go deeper to the different story and actually ask the person, there are some deep backstories that just make so much more sense and help us to recognize we're all human beings with limitations and with griefs and with sadness and that the world is a better place if we actually practice patients with each other. When we come back, how to build a scale of exercising patients. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
角度理解这个场景呢？从某种程度上说，这带来了一种好奇的导向，有助于培养耐心。但在我的经验中，当我花时间去深入了解那个不同的故事并真正去问那个人时，会有一些深刻的背景故事，让一切变得更有意义，并帮助我们认识到我们都是有局限性、有悲伤和痛苦的人，如果我们真正对彼此保持耐心，世界将会变得更美好。稍后回来，探讨如何建立培养耐心的阶梯。您正在收听的是《隐藏的脑》（Hidden Brain）。我是山卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。这里是《隐藏的脑》。我是山卡尔·维丹塔姆。
At Baylor University, psychologist Sarah Schnitker studies how we can train ourselves to become more patient. Sarah, as we discussed, there are many situations in which staying patient is not easy. Here's a message we received on that front from. listener Lauren. I just listened to the episode about patience and it was very eye-opening but also kind of hard for me to hear. I just turned 50 recently and I'm also also divorced recently. My career isn't going well at all. And as time has been going by, things just don't seem to be getting better. And I keep being told, oh, be patient. Things will be better. Be patient. Things will work out. And I guess at my age, I feel like there's this clock over my head and that I'm running out of time for things to get better.
在贝勒大学，心理学家莎拉·施尼特克研究了我们如何通过训练让自己变得更有耐心。莎拉，正如我们所讨论的，在许多情况下保持耐心并不容易。以下是我们收到的一位听众劳伦（Lauren）在这方面发来的信息。我刚听了关于耐心的那一期节目，它非常启发人心，但也让我有点难以接受。我最近刚满50岁，而且也刚离婚。我的事业一点也不顺利。随着时间的流逝，事情似乎并没有变好。人们总是对我说，“哦，要耐心点。事情会好起来的。要有耐心。一切都会顺利的。”我想以我的年龄，我感觉头顶上悬着一块表，我正在失去让事情变好的时间。
I feel like I only have so many productive years less. How could I possibly see solutions or fix all this and have it be worth it? How can I possibly be patient now? Sarah, I really feel for Lauren. Sometimes we feel we are not just rushing against deadlines, but against time itself. I also feel for Lauren, and my heart goes. out to her. And just this is not an uncommon experience, especially for people in midlife when they're facing transitions. And I think that what Lauren is expressing here is also just this existential
我觉得我剩下的有生产力的年头已经不多了。我怎么可能看到解决方案或解决这一切，并让它变得值得呢？我现在怎么可能保持耐心？莎拉，我真的很为劳伦感到难过。有时我们觉得我们不仅是在与截止日期赛跑，更是在与时间本身赛跑。我也很为劳伦感到心疼，我的心与她同在。这绝非一种罕见的经历，特别是对那些面临人生转型期中年阶段的人来说。而且我认为劳伦在这里表达的也是一种存在主义的
question that we all have limited time on this earth and that we all will die someday. And that I don't think there's any easy answers here. I think there are a couple things that could be helpful. And one thing is to focus on kind of reevaluating our bigger purpose in life when we come to such a juncture where we start to question where we're at. And if we have enough time to get where we want to be, that really thinking about what is my ultimate purpose and what do I want to accomplish for myself and also give back to my community in the days I have left on this earth? The second thing that I think might be helpful is to consider a lot of the wisdom that comes from different cultures and traditions across time and place that many communities, you see, deal with this question of our mortality in the fact that we don't live forever in a variety of ways that may or may not be helpful to a particular individual but are worth considering. For example, A lot of indigenous communities really focus on the seven generations principle of considering not just my own generation and what I do here and now, but the seven generations of my family
问题，即我们在地球上的时间有限，我们总有一天会死。我认为这里没有什么简单的答案。我认为有几件事可能会有所帮助。其中之一是，当我们走到这样一个开始质疑自己处境的人生十字路口时，重新评估我们在生活中的更大目标。如果我们有足够的时间到达我们想去的地方，那么就要认真思考：我的终极目标是什么？在我留在地球上的有限日子里，我想为自己完成什么，又想为我的社区回馈什么？我认为可能有帮助的第二件事是，去思考许多来自不同文化和传统、跨越时间和空间的智慧。你会发现，许多社区以各种各样的方式处理我们终有一死的问题——即我们不会长生不老这一事实。这些方式对某个特定的个体可能有帮助，也可能没有，但都值得考虑。例如，许多原住民社区真正关注“七代人原则”，不仅考虑我这一代以及我此时此地所做的事情，还要考虑我家族中
that will come after and that I'm part of a long string of my family and not just here and now. Likewise, a lot of your kind of traditional Judeo-Christian traditions and religious contexts focus on an afterlife and that this life is not all there is and there's more to come. And this helps us to think about patience differently when taking that kind of perspective. And so I feel for Lauren, I think this is not an easy question she's bringing up, but I hope she might be able to explore some of the ways folks have answered this from a lot of our wisdom traditions over time and be able to kind of reevaluate her big purpose right now. And see how that process might make her journey of patients be a little bit different.
未来将要到来的七代人，意识到我是家族长长历史链条中的一部分，而不仅仅局限于此时此地。同样，许多传统的犹太-基督教传统和宗教背景都关注来世，认为今生并非全部，未来还有更多。这种视角有助于我们以不同的方式思考耐心。因此，我为劳伦感到难过，我认为她提出的并不是一个简单的问题，但我希望她能够探索人们长期以来从我们的各种智慧传统中寻找答案的方式，并能够重新评估她眼前的宏大目标。看看这个过程是否能让她的耐心之旅变得略有不同。
We received a voice memo from a listener named Ross who talked about how patients can sometimes be a form of courage. To be patient with pain is much the same as being courageous about your pain. Here he is. I've experienced five major abdominal surgeries, the recovery from which in a hospital, one could legitimately say is brutal. And it takes time. You can't just lay there and feel sorry for yourself. You've got to get up and with the tree of pipes and wires and walk. That's how you get out of the hospital.
我们收到了一位名叫罗斯（Ross）的听众发来的语音备忘录，他谈到了耐心有时如何成为一种勇气。对痛苦保持耐心，在很大程度上就像是对你的痛苦保持勇敢。以下是他的录音。我经历过五次重大腹部手术，其中在医院的康复过程，完全可以说是一场残酷的考验。这需要时间。你不能只是躺在那里自怨自艾。你必须爬起来，带着一堆管子和导线四处走动。这就是你如何离开医院的方式。
You walk out. So this is an example of being patient with the discomfort and the time that it's going to take to recover. but having the courage to keep moving until you do. Talk about this idea, Sarah, the idea of being patient with your own discomfort. I can feel some of that discomfort in Ross's voice as he's describing this and just how brutal. Sometimes physical recovery can be. I think this is a really interesting example because we often, in this cultural context in particular, in the United States, but I think in other places as well, we just want to escape discomfort,
你走着离开。所以，这就是对不适感以及康复所需时间保持耐心的一个例子，但同时又要有勇气继续前进，直到康复。莎拉，谈谈这个观点吧，即对自己的不适感保持耐心的想法。当罗斯在描述这些经历以及身体康复过程有时是多么残酷时，我能从他的声音中感受到那种不适。我认为这是一个非常有趣的例子，因为我们——特别是在美国这种文化背景下，但我认为在其他地方也是如此——只想逃避不适感，
and we will do anything to do that. And so learning that I can enter into discomfort and do something like walking, which is a real challenge when you're recovering from surgery, that I have the bravery to get up and walk and then knowing that it's going to hurt. And I'm going to have to be patient with that pain as I continue this activity because it's a necessary pain to achieve my larger goal of healing and getting out of this hospital. And so I think this is just a great example of how courage and patience play out in real time and that if we try to escape or rush through pain, we won't actually achieve our goals. but that pain is sometimes, sometimes a signal that we need to stop.
我们会为了达到这个目的而不惜一切代价。因此，学会进入不适感并做一些像走路这样具有挑战性的事情——当你从手术中恢复时，这是一项真正的挑战——我有勇气站起来走路，并且知道这会很痛。随着我继续这项活动，我必须对这种痛苦保持耐心，因为这是实现我更大的治愈和出院目标的必要痛苦。所以我认为这绝对是一个绝佳的例子，展示了勇气和耐心如何在现实中发挥作用，如果我们试图逃避或匆忙摆脱痛苦，我们将无法真正实现我们的目标。但痛苦有时，
But sometimes we have to be patient with pain and persist through it because it's necessary. I'm thinking of childbirth, just how many women who have gone through the labor process would know this acutely, that there are some forms of pain that are good and need to be worked through, but that doesn't make it any easier to wait it out. and continue moving forward during that process. You're an academic, Sarah. You teach students all the time, and I'm thinking about the role of patience in learning. There's so much about learning that does involve sitting
有时是一个我们需要停下来的信号。但有时我们必须对痛苦保持耐心并坚持下去，因为这是必要的。我想到了分娩，许多经历过分娩过程的女性对此都有着切身的体会，她们知道有些痛苦是好的，需要去克服，但这并不能让等待痛苦过去、并在整个过程中继续前行变得哪怕容易一点点。莎拉，你是一位学者。你一直在教导学生，我在思考耐心在学习中的作用。学习中有很大一部分确实涉及去忍受
with the discomfort of your own ignorance or the discomfort of you're not being able to understand something. And I think so many of us, many students certainly, but really everyone, even people who are not in college or school, try and take shortcuts and basically say let's cut out this discomfort that I'm feeling about not understanding how a quadratic equation works or how, you know, the history of this movement connects with the history of this other movement. Talk about the value of patience when it comes to learning. Yes. You know, patience is essential for learning. And I do see students often
自己无知的痛苦，或者无法理解某个事物的痛苦。我认为我们当中的许多人，许多学生当然如此，但实际上每个人，甚至那些不在大学或学校里的人，都试图走捷径，基本上就是说：让我们消除这种因不理解二次方程是如何运作的、或者这种运动的历史如何与另一种运动的历史相联系而感受到的不适感吧。谈谈在学习时保持耐心的价值。是的。你知道，耐心对学习至关重要。我确实看到学生经常
want to rush to get there. And instead of saying, oh, this is taking time, this is something that's difficult or this is something that must be really worthwhile because it's taking me so much time to understand it. I think some of their first responses, this is taking me time, means either it's not worth learning or something's wrong with me. And that I should be able to learn this quickly, especially some of my brightest students. They can struggle with this the most. And so I do a lot of conversations, especially with my PhD students, the best and the brightest, who have been able to learn so much already to just normalize that learning anything difficult is going to take you so much more time than you realize it will. And especially for learning a skill like writing
想要急于求成。他们不是去想，“哦，这需要时间，这是一件困难的事情，或者这是一件非常值得去做的事情，因为我花了这么多时间去理解它”，而是把这当作他们的第一反应。他们认为花时间意味着要么这不值得学，要么自己出了什么毛病。他们觉得，特别是那些最聪明的学生，自己应该能够很快学会这一点，而他们在这方面往往挣扎得最厉害。所以我经常与人交谈，特别是与我的博士生——那些最优秀、最聪明、已经学到了如此多东西的人——进行交流，以让他们认识到：学习任何困难的东西所花费的时间都会比你意识到的要多得多。特别是对于学习写作这样的技能
or advanced mathematics or really any skill that really requires expertise, it's going to take you a while to get there. And that is not a signal that you don't have what it takes. It's a signal that this is something worthwhile. As we wrap up our conversation, Sarah, I'm reminded of something one of my heroes once said. Mahatma Gandhi said that violence often was a form of impatience. So we see something we don't like. we want to change it quickly, we find we cannot change it quickly, and so we resort to force.
或高等数学，或者真正需要专业知识的任何技能，你都需要花上一段时间才能掌握。这并不意味着你没有这块料。这说明这是一件值得去做的事情。在我们结束谈话之际，莎拉，我想起了我的一位偶像曾经说过的话。圣雄甘地曾说过，暴力通常是不耐烦的一种形式。所以当我们看到不喜欢的事物时，我们想要迅速改变它，却发现无法迅速改变，于是便诉诸武力。
What do you think of this idea, Sarah? This is a fantastic idea. I am also a huge fan of Gandhi and his work and all the other amazing work inspired around the world. I think he's right that violence is most often caused by impatience, that we want things to happen in a certain way and in a certain time frame. and human beings can't always be put on a clock, and especially not our own clock in the way we would like things to happen. And as societies over kind of history, when we look back, when they've resorted to violence, it's often begotten more violence. And that instead, the really significant and long-lasting movements that lead to peace and prosperity for all members of us, society have recognized that impatience is not the answer. And then instead, we need to really
莎拉，你如何看待这个想法？这是一个绝妙的想法。我也是甘地及其著作以及世界各地所有其他受其启发的伟大工作的超级粉丝。我认为他是对的，暴力最常由不耐烦引起，我们希望事情能以某种特定的方式并在某个特定的时间框架内发生。而人类并不总能被塞进时钟里，尤其是不能按照我们希望事情发生的节奏塞进我们自己的时钟里。回顾历史，当人类社会诉诸暴力时，它往往会引发更多的暴力。相反，那些真正通往和平与繁荣、惠及我们社会所有成员的重大且长久的历史运动，都认识到不耐烦并不是答案。相反，我们需要真正
consider the rights and desires of other human beings as equal to our own and that we need to take routes of persuasion and nonviolent protest and nonviolent action that this is when we actually see a society that is peaceful, that respects the rights of all. And people and that really is typified by love and by justice and is what many of us would want to live in what we would call a society that allows people to live a good life. And so I know in my own life, I often feel the temptation to push people and to enact my own will, even not with physical violence, but with other forms of kind of pushing. And when each of us, you know, can recognize patience is a gift we give, and it's a gift that comes back and benefits us
将其他人类的权利和愿望视为与我们自己平等的东西，并且我们需要采取说服、非暴力抗议和非暴力行动的途径。只有这样，我们才能真正看到一个和平的、尊重所有人权利的社会。而且这真正体现为爱与正义，是我们许多人所向往的生活环境，也就是我们所说的允许人们过上美好生活的社会。所以我知道在我的生活中，我也经常感受到想要逼迫他人、推行自己意志的诱惑，即使不是通过身体暴力，也是通过其他形式的施压。当我们在座的每一个人，能够认识到耐心是我们给予的一份礼物，是一份会回馈并造福我们的
in our relationships and in our society. I think really can lead to the kind of flourishing society, flourishing life all of us desire. What we see is that we are patient with those we love and we begin to love those to whom we are patient, that patience is sometimes the first step. And when we allow the person, the space, to be who they are, we actually can start to appreciate who they are and begin to feel compassion and love, especially when we're talking about people who disagree with us, who we might consider our enemies. Patients can help to cultivate a stance towards others that allows us to remember they are human beings as well, and not just our enemies, our opponents,
关系和社会的礼物时，我认为这确实能引领我们走向每个人都渴望的繁荣社会、繁荣生活。我们所看到的是，我们对所爱之人保持耐心，我们开始爱那些我们对之保持耐心的人，耐心有时是第一步。当我们给予对方空间去成为他们自己时，我们实际上可以开始欣赏他们是谁，并开始感受到同情和爱，尤其是当我们谈论那些与我们意见相左、我们可能视为敌人的人时。耐心可以帮助我们培养一种对其他人的态度，让我们记住他们也是人类，而不仅仅是我们的敌人、我们的对手，
but part of our society and valuable contributors, even if we disagree with them. Sarah Schnitker is a psychologist at Baylor University. She is the director of the Baylor Research and Growth and Human Thriving Science Center. Sarah, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me, Shankar. It's been a real pleasure.
而是我们社会的一部分，是有价值的贡献者，即使我们与他们意见不一致。莎拉·施尼特克是贝勒大学的心理学家。她是贝勒大学研究、成长与人类蓬勃发展科学中心的主任。莎拉，非常感谢你今天做客《隐藏的脑》。谢谢你邀请我，山卡尔。这真的是一次非常愉快的经历。
Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy, Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you enjoyed today's conversation, please share it with a few friends, family members, or co-workers.
《隐藏的脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲（Annie Murphy）、保罗（Paul）、克里斯汀·王（Kristen Wong）、劳拉·克雷尔（Laura Querell）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）、安德鲁·查德里克（Andrew Chadwick）和尼克·伍德伯里（Nick Woodbury）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制作人。我是《隐藏的脑》的执行主编。如果你喜欢今天的对话，请把它分享给一些朋友、家人或同事。
If they don't listen right away, channel your inner Sarah Schnitker and be patient. You can show them again next week. I'm Shankar Vedantham. See you soon. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果他们没有立即听，请释放你内心的莎拉·施尼特克，保持耐心。你可以在下周再向他们展示。我是山卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们很快再见。谢谢。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。